Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu ukw unsere kleine welt die hier in unregelmäßigen abständen beleuchtet.
Und zuletzt ging's um den brexit davor ging's um hongkong und ja,
jetzt wollte ich dann aber auch gleich da sich hier auch die ereignisse überschlagen haben zu hongkong nochmal was nachliefern,
und sag erstmal hallo zu der heute dabei ist.
Hallo tim.
In meinem podcast zu kurdistan,
das ist ja so ein bisschen so der kern deiner expertise kann man sagen,
wobei aber auch viel zur sprache kam dass du dich eigentlich so über das engagement in kurdistan so ein bisschen zum journalisten entwickelt hast,
kann man so sagen ne so auch so seiten einsteiger wäre.
Ja
Wer arbeitet heute schon in den beruf die man gelernt hat genau wenn das interessiert kann er gerne mal reinhören heute geht's,
um hongkong denn was ich nicht erzählt habe als ich die letzte
sendung zur hongkong gemacht habe ist dass ich zu dem zeitpunkt schon wusste dass sie ein paar tage nach hongkong fahren würde es hat sich bei mir kurzfristig ergeben und ja da war das interesse dann irgendwie zu groß waren vergleichsweise
kurzer aufenthalt also ich war letztlich nur drei tage vor ort,
aber die gelegenheit war günstig um einfach mal selber ein gefühl zu entwickeln,
was denn da eigentlich so abgeht was denn da eigentlich so passiert.
Und ich stelle fest
kaum ist man so gefühlt auf der anderen seite des planeten tummelt sich in der ganzen stadt leute die man kennt das war wirklich erschlagen manche hab ich auch nur kurz
um wenige tage verpasst man kriegt ihr die tür nicht zu,
naja und kaum war ich da erreicht mich dann sozusagen auch schon der hinweis auf twitter ja hier der nur der ist auch gerade unterwegs wir so ja okay alles klar ich kann man seine ruhe auf jeden fall nicht haben,
na ja für mich war es das erste mal für dich war es ja nicht das erste mal dass du nach hongkong gefahren bist oder.
Er ich war zweitausenddreizehn da aber auch nur ein paar tage um vortrag zu halten also so so ähnlich wie du jetzt wahrscheinlich einfach kurz ein paar sachen erledigen und wieder zurück.
Ja was war das.
Zweitausenddreizehn irgendwie ich glaube im herbst oder so ja.
Also schon eine weile her und jetzt war es ja wieder so ein anlass.
Ja genau also ich bin von der gleichen uni zum gleichen thema eingeladen worden sozusagen was über kurdistan erzählen jetzt über die aktuelle lage warum die amis abgezogen sind äh was da sonst nicht so ergibt und.
Warum man da immer irgendwas von hört aber eigentlich nichts konkretes also jeder weiß es gibt irgendwie kurdistan und irgendwas ist da los aber dann so rum genau also im detail auch nicht.
Der hat mich halt eingeladen einfach um sozusagen update zu geben für die studenten die es interessiert.
Und hat's wieder interessiert.
Ja also sie haben gesagt für dafür dass es.
Aus hongkong hat sich ein spezialthema ist da waren so dreißig leute was ja sagten was für ihre vorträge da gut ist.
Einer der leute dort war der vize generalkonsul der türkei.
Der es irgendwie geschickt worden um eine erklärung zu verlesen der hat eine einseitige erklärung nachher verlesen was sie alles gutes für die kurden in der türkei tun.
Und für flüchtlinge und warum sie die geilsten sind das war nur ein bisschen lustig.
Unaufgefordert.
Ja also ich habe ihn nicht drum gebeten.
Ja aber die unia vielleicht oder.
Nee auch nicht so richtig sie haben gesagt sie möchten es jetzt auch nicht verbieten oder irgendwas also wenn ich da jetzt kein kommentar paar satte jeder darf sich zum deppen machen also ich meine freies
was nur ein bisschen lustig war war sein einstie
er sagte ja ich habe jetzt diesen vortrag hier irgendwie zugehört und mir ein paar notizen dazu gemacht und hatte die ganze zeit so ein ausgedruckte dina vier zettel vor sich liegen das wohl seine spontanen erstellt notizen darstellen sollte.
Und,
dann hat er fünf sechs minuten das runtergerannt hat und dann gefragt ob ich dazu irgendwas sagen möchte und ich habe halt gedacht so so typisch wie auf twitter will ich jetzt mit dem troll zu tun haben und hab immer gesagt nö so nächste frage,
und lustig war war das ein student irgendwie sagte er hätte da noch eine anmerkung zu okay,
sagte ja also nur so ein tipp fürs nächste mal wenn man sagt man hat sich gerade notizen gemacht dann sollte man nicht mit einem ausgedruckt nina vier papier seid nach stunde hier sitzen.
Ja aber erst mal irgendwie so erbärmlich komisch war ja gehört halt dazu.
Bemerkenswert dass sie dass sie wirklich in hong kong also würde ich also ganz anderen ort dass ich auf einmal genötigt für kleine veranstaltung an der uni also.
Ich kann die nicht mal mit türkei dem thema sozusagen zu tun hat er die kam so am am rande irgendwie vor als war aber also es war jetzt nicht mal der kern der sache,
also das ich hab auch gedacht was was für ein ego problem haben die oder wie auch immer,
weil nur dadurch fand ich wurde dieser vortrag für mich nach außen überhaupt erwähnenswert also sonst hätte ich gesagt ich habe da einen vortrag gehalten so wie immer nicht spannendes aber das hat sozusagen,
die sache erst interessant gemacht oder berichten es wert aus meiner sicht oder so ja.
Du darüber berichtet oder andere darüber berichten.
Nicht also dass ich da sozusagen auf facebook und so breit getreten habe so hey da ist was passiert sonst hätte ich gesagt hier ein foto haben vortrag gehalten fertig also.
Was dann gleich wieder nachricht.
Irgendwie ja also wie immer nicht 'ne riesen reich weiterbauen gemerkt hat das interessiert dann doch leute wenn sich jemand so zum deppen macht aus,
kein grund also irgendwie,
komisch halt also irgendwie ja ich dachte auch da fliegt ja neuntausend kilometer um irgendwie oder oder seit neuntausend kilometer von wo ich sonst bin entfernt,
nur um mir zu sagen dass ihr den vortrag nicht mögt also wie nötig kann man's haben also wie bei glaube das ist doch beim anhalter dieser eine der unsterblich oder sowas und rumreißen und alle beleidigt.
Bauwagen der unendlich verlängerte.
Genau also so so ist es.
Tritt ist weil er weil er unsterblich ist und dann sich auskotzen muss.
Und ich dachte vielleicht ist er auch so dass der quer durch die welt geschickt wird vielleicht hat er irgendwann mal scheiße gebaut und hat jetzt die arschkarte und sowas machen aber irgendwie daran hat mich erinnert,
ja das war so was ganz interessant war bei dem vortrag oder davor,
hat mich jemand angesprochen der unterrichtet journalismus einer anderen uni und da haben wir uns halt über presse und so in in hongkong unterhalten.
Der sagt halt das welche von seinen studenten halt in irgendwelchen nachrichten studios oder so schon arbeiten oder so nebenjobs haben also ein bisschen journalistisch tätig sind,
und das von denen auch einige festgenommen worden sind also die als journalisten unterwegs waren sagte das war,
nicht so richtig will die sind da meist am nächsten morgen rausgekommen oder die uni hat sich halt gemeldet und gesagt hey das sind unsere studenten hier die brauchen wir noch schickt die mal wieder los sag das war relativ schnell die sachen zu klären,
aber überhaupt dass man sozusagen so am unteren ende vom journalismus einfache leute fest nimmt,
nur dass sie eigentlich vor den füßen rumlaufen sagt er das ist zumindest nicht wie es früher war.
So dass der vortrag war ja nicht am ersten tag dann ersten tag wo du dann
wieder die augen öffnen konntest haben wir dann die zeit nutzen müssen gemeinsam durch die stadt gestritten haben uns mal so ein bisschen einen eindruck zu machen und ich würde sagen wir hatten so ein etwa denselben eindruck ist ja
ist ja eigentlich ganz friedlich hier so ne also man.
Also ganz interessant kaum kaum war ich da wurde ich irgendwie von allen seiten bombardiert von so freunde die mitbekommen haben das nach so ja pass auf dich auf und es ist ganz schlimm.
So ohne verzehrte wahrnehmung und das hatte dann damit zu tun was ich in dem moment ja auch noch nicht so wusste weil ich im wesentlichen mitfliegen beschäftigt,
wesen bin das an dem wochenende es schon wieder an verschiedenen stellen sehr eskaliert ist.
Mein erster tag war dann montag so wir haben uns dann am mittwoch ja erst gesehen,
da war dann gefühlt nicht viel los man wusste zwar irgendwo ist immer irgendwas,
aber es ist eben jetzt auch nicht so dass die ganze stadt brennt und man das gefühl hat weltuntergang dann wenn überhaupt war das so nadelstiche
aktionen an orten indem man sich halt gerade nicht aufgehalten hat es gab es keine verkehrssperrungen oder sonst irgendwas so.
Also so wie in berlin halt alltag also irgendwo ist immer irgend 'ne demo und manchmal wirft auch jemand was oder
man liest irgendwie ja in der liebe straße sind irgendwie sachen hin und her geflogen so ja okay so und also ich denke das ist ja das gleiche hier wenn du hier als tuch herum läuft dass du irgendwie kann mag sein aber wenn ich gemerkt ne.
Genau und andere gucken irgendwie fernsehen rights in berlin weil er wieder erst dabei oder so furchtbar und.
Haben alle wieder aus drei perspektiven die gleichen mülltonne gefilmt die irgendwie angezündet hat ja und das war auch so meine sozusagen meine erwartungshaltung als ich rübergeflogen wenn ihr es wird schon irgendwo sein aber naja.
Und das war dann auch stimmig mit dem was mir leute die ich getroffen habe die vor ort gewohnt haben so expert et cetera die meinten auch so naja das wäre halt so eigentlich der modus und trotzdem waren die,
einbußen für den tourismus wohl schon signifikant ja also alle erzählt mir mal so ja wenn sie dann irgendwie durch die städte das alles voll und überall leute und wenn du da irgendwie in dieses shopping maul zentrum gehst und so die tür nicht zu
es war halt nirgendwo so richtig voll dann hörte ich halt auch so naja normalerweise wär's eigentlich richtig voll aber durch die ganze berichterstattung durch diese ganzen,
proteste sind tatsächlich tourismus zahlen erheblich zurückgegangen.
Ja auch mit der metro wenn man darum gefahren ist also mit der mdr irgendwie ich kam immer in den ersten zug der reinkam und da war so,
durchschnittlich voll also so ein bisschen enger aber auch nicht so diese szenen die ich im kopf hatte von du stapels noch die leute und die frage kommentierst erstmal das noch eine reinpasst oder so sondern so aus berliner sicht jetzt überhaupt nicht spektakulär,
also dachte auflösen irgendwie.
Dass es dir fragen mit tieren ist so eine japanische nummer finde ich.
Ja mit den stecken ne das ja eher komprimieren schon,
ja ich dachte auch so alles also so sagen wir mal nicht voller und nicht lehrer als in berlin aber dafür dass es hongkong ist hätte ich halt zehn mal so viel erwartet oder so,
nicht so das gleiche was ich hier so aus mitte oder so kenne.
Na weil die stadt ist ja an sich sehr kompakt gebaut
es ist ja ohnehin nicht viel fläche da und viel wird von steilen bergen eingenommen wo dann einfach nicht sehr viel organisiert werden kann und überall da wo es dann halt flaches plus eben was so an land gewinnung da noch
gefunden hat da hat man natürlich auch ein paar neben dem anderen das schon irgendwie auch krass denkt immer so so okay große schnell das ist,
zu sagen so so fühlt es sich dann also an kurz bevor wir so in dieser fantasie sind,
aber ansonsten alles ganz gemütlich man ist also im november schönes wetter es regnet nicht.
Wenn so fünfundzwanzig grad am tag also echt optimal eigentlich.
Und auch diese diese wolkenkratzer und so und ich denke was es so von der desktop ie wegnimmt das ist nicht dreckig oder gefährlich also so oft,
assoziiert man ja denke ich mit so wolkenkratzer schlachten
da sind dann die kriminellen zwischen und irgendwie und das ist alles merkwürdig und da hat man ja irgendwie nie da,
dass es irgendwie gefährlich oder schlimm oder also es hat so einen gewissen maß an dreckig zeit aber den überschreitet,
wird es auch nicht oder so also nicht nicht das land oder sowas.
Ne nichts nichts was man nicht aus berlin zumindest gewohnt wäre.
Ja ja aber nicht mal eine couch auf dem gehweg oder so.
Das stimmt insofern ist der prenzlauer berg schon schlimmer.
Ja also ich fand so,
sauberer als berlin also nicht viel und vielleicht ein bisschen anders aber,
da sagen wir dieses individuelle müll abladen auf der straße irgendwie nicht,
aber das eine mal kam an unseren bollerwagen mit zwei schweinehälften vorbei die so,
also erstmal nicht verpackt und nix waren und der wagen sei es auch nicht besonders sicher aus und die waren also sah so wie gerade frisch auseinander gesägt aus und der riesling noch an der einen seite so dran also ich dachte so also anders,
aber eben nicht dieses dieses gefährliche slam artige oder wie man sich so das klischee von der branche vorstellt oder so,
sondern ich finde das macht auch so merkwürdig dass das
also das da so zwei klischees übereinander kommen so die sauberen chinesen die immer alles schön putzen als das eine klischee und das andere so diese hochhaus schlucht die doch eigentlich so das ghetto sein müssten oder so und das ist so beides halt nicht.
Ja das stimmt da ist unsere assoziation glaube ich auch mit hochhäusern eine eine andere,
also entweder banken viertel äh oder eben wohngeld und da ist es halt einfach,
normal naja von daher konnte ich dann,
glücklicherweise kann man jetzt sagen wenig selbst beobachten wo es jetzt irgendwie wild abging ich hatte dann so am letzten,
abend als ich so etwas später noch ein bisschen durch die gassen zu tauchen dann hatte ich dann schon so eine situation,
kamera so vom vom essen aus dem laden raus und auf einmal waren so überall junge gestalten schwarz gekleidet mit mundschutz,
da war dann keine auseinandersetzung aber was was ich sofort bemerkte war da war so eine ganz zielgerichtete bewegung am start so also das war so ein movement ist mir in dem moment mehr so.
Rückzug vielleicht das falsche wort ich hatte ja so den eindruck,
so die sind sozusagen jetzt eher dabei sich wieder so in ihrer,
wohnung zurück zu orientieren aber es waren schon auffällig viele auf einmal die so aus dem nichts von mir auftauchten,
keine aggression oder so einfach nur leute in bewegung,
merke ich halt sofort so okay alles klar ihr seid auf jeden fall,
dabei so und euch euch gibt es auch,
ja und für dich ging es dann aber noch ein bisschen anders weiter also ich hatte dann quasi montag bis mittwoch muss dann am donnerstag wieder zurück und.
Beziehungsweise am mittwochabend bin ich dann zurückgeflogen zum wochenende hin bekam aber die sache dann offensichtlich wieder thermik.
Wie ging's dir denn dann.
Das war ganz komisch weil in den nächsten tagen also auch bevor ich dann am donnerstag den vortrag gehalten hab hab ich ja so ein bisschen zeit ziehen gemacht,
kalou wald city was ja auch so ein eigenes,
also so was ja so dass das getto war in dem anarchie geherrscht hat kurz gesagt so und da ist heute im park und den wollte ich mir einfach angucken sowas in der nähe von der uni ist und so wirklich normale touri kram und dann freitag auch,
nach macau gefahren mit diesem highspeed drüber und noch abgefahren kram als hongkong angucken also man kakao ist er nochmal irgendwie 'ne andere welt.
Das ist die seite portugiesische exklave die halt.
Genau auf der anderen seite der bucht ist so.
Genau aber heute im wesentlichen eigentlich casino ist so ein bisschen so ein las vegas geworden ne.
Und halt so wie wie halt hongkong so britisch geprägt ist marco halt,
portugiesisch geprägt mit portugiesischen straßen schildern und so dazwischen.
Auch so wieso außen stellen von denen las vegas casino aus also zumindest mit den gleichen namen und gleichen logos,
also irgendwie sowas bizarre zwischen so einer portugiesischen kleinstadt und las vegas und das auf so eine insel zusammen gefährt also so einfach.
Wo man mal ein tag gucken geht damit man etwas verrücktes gesehen hat.
Und am abend.
Dann einfach nur in der nähe vom hotel also zurück in hongkong wollten wir was essen gehen und,
sind erstmal in so eine trauerfeier gelaufen weil ich glaube an dem tag vorher ich meine am donnerstag ist der eine junge hongkong er von so einem parkhaus gestürzt irgendwie auf der flucht vor der polizei,
und ist gestorben also so und dann ging halt die gerüchte los von der wut geschubst bis hin zu die polizei hat gar nichts mit zu tun das war ein selbstmord also so wie immer die ganze bandbreite die man nicht,
also so überhaupt nicht einschätzen kann auch also und.
Da war einfach wie so eine trauerfeier also wirklich hunderte oder also ich hab so grob länge mal breite gezählt und kam es auf knapp zweitausend leute die da waren auf zwei ebene also plus minus arbeit eine große masse leute,
auch also diese sama zum großen teil jüngere leute.
So im studenten oder schüler alter viele in in dunkel also nicht so komplett schwarz wie der schwarze block gekleidet aber schon so sagen wir eintönig dunkel.
Aber eben auch so normale geschäftsleute der normale menschen dazwischen also ich würd mal sagen achtzig prozent junge leute aber auch ein deutlicher satz von anderen.
Die da einfach nur ruhig standen und gesungen haben oder einfach nur ganz ruhig waren und so texte mit kerzen ausgelegt haben und blumen niedergelegt haben und sowas also einfach so eine ruhige trauerveranstaltung.
Und.
Da war es aber so also das war so da wo ich eigentlich was essen gehen wollte und da habe ich gedacht na aber mal gucken zum einen also sozusagen ich habe sowas nicht gesucht aber ich gehe dann ja auch nicht dran vorbei sondern will dann ja schon wissen was ist da jetzt.
Das war halt irgendwie ein bisschen also ich kenne von hier,
keine richtig vergleichbaren veranstaltungen also hier gibt 's mal eine trauer minute dann gibt's text beiträge und so aber dass ich sozusagen adhoc so 'ne menge menschen treffen und da einfach gemeinsam ruhig trauern so also das ging ich weiß nicht 'ne halbe stunde oder 'ne stunde oder so.
Und halt wirklich alle gesittet und ruhig und artig.
Und dann so die details die einem auffüllen ich bin halt mit der kamera da durchgegangen zu gucken was los ist und ein paar fotos zu schießen und alle leute machen so automatisch platz also nicht dass man sich durchschieben musste sondern dass man wieso ein spalier bekam dass man immer zwischen den durchgehen konnte,
ich dachte dass es irgendwie,
einfach also anders als hier kenne ich man schiebt sich durch und es ist ruhig und okay aber das alle wirklich auf einen achten und deinen platz machen war irgendwie dachte okay die die achten auf dinge.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht was ich mit der information anfangen voll soll aber man man merkt halt irgendwie aufmerksame leute und.
Den eindruck dass es eine reaktion auf dich als nicht chinese ist oder.
Das war in,
ja in dem moment war schwierig weil ich sonst weit und breit niemand gesehen hatte weil ich genau das gucken wollte so ist das im vergleich anders aber habe ich da nicht gesehen.
Und aber also grundsätzlich dass ich ein bisschen anders behandelt wurde ich dann schon gemerkt also weil immer wieder.
Mich leute angesprochen haben und mir also kurz erklärt haben worum es da geht ich dachte das ist ja schon mal nett also so die merken der kommt wahrscheinlich nicht von hier und dann mal grob sagen was ist sache.
Da aber auch schon dass wir immer welche gesagt haben aber pass auf wenn die polizei kommt sie zu dass wir hier wegkommst also das ist dann gefährlich.
Da dachte ich auch so das kenne ich von anderen sachen nicht also selbst wenn man hier so eine neonazi demo beobachten geht.
Dann geht man da hin und guckt aber da kommt nicht da und leute sagen und pass auf wenn die kommen oder wenn die recht kommen dann wird sie gefährlich sondern man geht irgendwie von aus das weiß man oder es ist egal,
aber das fand ich auch irgendwie komisch und auch nicht dass man,
gefühl hatte das sind so deppen dir die polizei dämonisierung wollen und die irgendwie panik,
machen oder sowas sondern einfach so wie so ein höflicher hinweis so also so du bist nicht von hier halt lieber abstand.
Es gab ja auch eine änderung es wurde mir dann auch gesagt das habe ich so noch vorher gar nicht mitbekommen dass
die proteste am anfang einfach so stattfanden und das war irgendwie alles soweit okay nur wurden sie dann vor das weiß ich ganz genau wenn das so war voll ein zwei monaten glaube ich auch offiziell verboten,
und damit war schon eine beteiligung problematisch sowohl für leute die zum staats dienst sind lehrer et cetera die mussten sozusagen schon befürchten dann eben entsprechende sanktionen zu erleiden wenn sie da auch nur gesehen werden
zunehmenden maße kam dann auch so die empfehlung mit naja wenn ihr sozusagen nicht von hier seid dann haltet euch besser auch mal fern,
sonst werdet ihr halt gleich irgendwie behandelt.
Das war so ich hatte es da eine weile gesehen und dachte okay habe ich gesehen hab ich verstanden gehe ich weiter also so weil irgendwie so interessant so dann hat man mal gesehen wo wovon wovon wir so sprechen wenn es darum geht,
und und dann auf dem weg weiter da lang.
So durch diese kleineren straßen kam halt also es war irgendwie auf einmal so laut halt umgedreht und da waren so irgendwas zwischen hundert und zweihundert.
Von denen so vermuten also black heißen die da ja so vermute junge leute mit eisenstangen und helm und.
Alle möglichen die einfach auf der straße lang zogen und so stück für stück die.
Kreuzung blockiert haben mit mülleimer oder straßen schildern und so,
und einfach so zur nächsten zogen was ich da irgendwie interessant fand so was ich hier aus deutschland kenne wenn man eine kreuzung irgendwie verbarrikadiert will.
Dann wird da richtig große zeug dran geschleppt,
dass man zumindest mit einem normalen auto nicht durchkommt ohne dass das auto kaputt geht oder so da dass man halt wirklich eine barriere schafft die gewissen schutz bietet oder sowas,
und die haben zum teil so wieso mobile bushaltestellen oder so einfach so umgekippt also dass da einfach so ein schild was man alleine anheben konnte quer über eine spur lag.
Und daneben irgendwie so 'n so 'n verkehrs blond und mülleimer oder so aber kam den man echt mit dem fuß wegschieben konnte also ich dachte das ist ja keine,
da war kein richtiges hindernis da kann's jetzt aussteigen also denkt immer so der typische berliner taxifahrer der wird das eben mit dem fußweg treten und weiterfahren,
oder einfach drüber fahren und da blieben aber alle stehen und sind nicht mehr aus dem auto ausgestiegen nach und nach stiegen welche aus.
Da nur auch mich gewundert haben die angst vor den leuten also sozusagen dass wenn sie's wegräumen diese vermuten wiederkommen und sie zusammen drin oder.
Kennen diese situation nicht und sind einfach überfordert.
Oder ist das wie so eine stille unterstützung dass man sagt oh schade hier kann ich nicht mehr durch ist jetzt äh blockiert da muss ich auch stehen bleiben oder so also warum steigt die leute nicht aus und machen was.
Und ich hatte dann welche angesprochen also einfach gefragt so,
und die wollten aber nicht so mit mir reden also diese normalen autofahrer sagt nee ähm müssen sie nicht sehen sie nicht genau keine ahnung also so irgendwie so so freundliches abbiegen aber wo klar war also will man keine aussage zu treffen oder so.
Und diesem wer dieser gruppe von von leuten.
Bin ich dann mit so 'n paar meter abstand gefolgt weil ich halt dachte ich will ja schon irgendwie sehen was die machen oder wie also
verprügeln die jetzt leute machen die läden kaputt gehen die auf öffentliche einrichtungen sind die was an also es kann ja so sehr verschiedene dinge sein.
Das finde ich immer wieder interessant wenn es heißt na sind halt so autonome oder sowas denke aber was machen die also ich finde das eine sehr wichtige fall unterscheidung gegen wen gehen sie wie vor.
Und das problem war halt die waren also halt komplett vermutet.
Auch zum teil dann mit so na wieso einfachen protektoren am oberkörper oder sowieso motocross protektoren oder so.
Dass man aber auch die statur nicht gut einschätzen kann und.
Also für mich macht doch ein unterschied habe ich da jemand der offensichtlich das erste mal rausgeht und irgendwie war schlichtweg so ein schmaler netter junger mann ist der offensichtlich irgendwie auf die straße getrieben wurde weil das benötigt hält.
Oder sieht das aus wie so 'n berufskollegen der einem gleich,
hand den kopf abreißen kann also einfach umso einzuschätzen wie viel abstand sollte man halten oder sieht er jetzt grimmig aus oder nicht.
Das kommt man halt alles überhaupt nicht einschätzen was die sache so a so unangenehm macht und auch haben jetzt ein problem damit dass ich nebenher laufen und fotos machen.
Oder freuen sie sich drüber und da kam von denen so null reaktion also ich wurde einfach ignoriert,
und das hat irgendwie für mich auch nicht besser gemacht weil ich so dachte okay die haben zum teil wirklich so meter lange eisen latten wenn mir einer schlecht gesonnen ist und der brett mein über dann ist ganz ganz schlecht.
Und auf der anderen seite vielleicht stört die das ja auch gar nicht ja genau dass ich da so zuschauen das war aber so.
Und das denke ich wenn man das so später erzählt klingt das immer so irgendwie so trivial halt,
so ja guckt man halt aber in dem moment wenn man dazwischen irgendwie hundert zweihundert leuten ist die man nicht einschätzen kann das ist schon so also so so,
dieses spannungsfeld zwischen ich will ja sehen was da passiert und ich will es einschätzen können wenn ich schon die chance habe,
und zum anderen hab ich aber keine ahnung was grade los ist und ob das gefährlich ist oder ob's völlig ungefährlich ist und ich da quasi paranoide zwischen stehe und mir völlig unbegründet sorgen mache,
und das fand ich echt nicht einfach.
Zu welchem schluss bist du gekommen.
Ich bin dann zum schluss gekommen wenn sie was gegen mich hätten dann hätten sie relativ schnell wer irgendwer gekommen und hätte mich wenigstens verscheucht oder bedroht oder so.
Und dadurch dass keiner reagiert kann zumindest nicht schlecht sein,
also ich denke hier hatte ich immer wieder wenn leute irgendwas auf demos gemacht haben was sagen wir mal nicht ganz legal war dann hieß es regelmäßig ey hier keine keine fotos oder geh mal weg oder so also auch nicht bedrohlich aber das klar geäußert wurde hier nicht.
Und da dachte ich auch noch irgendwer würde schon irgendwas sozusagen zeigen.
Und das interessante entscheidende war dann eigentlich 'ne gefährlichere situation davon.
Ich hab ein foto gemacht und hab nur gesehen dass irgendwas von oben geflogen kam und bin so weg gesprungen und dann ist quasi neben mir so 'ne metall latte eingeschlagen nehmen so nah.
Ja so einer kleinen barrikade und die hatte scheinbar jemand von oben geschmissen aber um sie sozusagen auf die barrikade noch drauf zu werfen,
der hatte mich nicht gesehen und wurde oben von seinen freund oder was das war schon gehauen und an gebrüllt und rief dann runter hier sorry sorry ich habe dich nicht gesehen und so wo ich dachte okay das offen also,
unterm strich kann man es als positiv werden so aber.
Wie knapp hat die dich verfehlt.
Meter oder so also schon also so im bereich man sagt mir,
ja genau also so hätte ich doch eher fünf meter abstand halten sollen wäre ich weiter weg gewesen ne also irgendwie so mittel.
Und dann dachte ich aber okay dann kann man da wohl so dich daran.
Und habe mir das halt ein paar minuten angeguckt und nach weiß gar nicht,
viertelstunde zwanzig minuten oder sowas als scheinbar die polizei kam oder absehbar war dass die kam.
Haben sie sich also ein großteil davon in rekordzeit umgezogen also so rechts und links in die ganz schmalen gassen es gibt für die normalen straßen.
Und dann gibt's teilweise zwischen den häusern so schlucken die so ein zwei meter nur bereit sind mit so wo die mülltonnen und so drin stehen und da verspannt die rein dann bin ich da auch mal hinterher gegangen und die zeigt mir noch nicht soll zur seite gehen also nicht so blöd in der.
Also in diesem weg quasi stehen sondern auch zum rand gehen dass man mich nicht so sieht,
und zogen sich dann einfach von so schwarz vom mund auf knalle bund um also so irgendwie also schwarze t-shirt aus und den mundschutz aus und den helm runter und irgendein neonfarben des t-shirt mit einer hello kitty figur oder so drauf du überhaupt.
Ein paar hatten so selfie sticks dabei oder irgend so ein blödsinn und was ich dann erst,
später richtig kapiert habe ein paar hatten so starbucks becher einfach bei uns,
der minute liefen sie so mit dem selfie-stick und im starbucks becher mit ihren freunden lachen durch die straße.
Vor dem touristen wo das sozusagen.
Später ich dann noch kapiert dass da wachsen.
Dort zu einem konzern gehört den sie sozusagen als den feind sehen also wo man sozusagen nochmal einen drauf setzen sagt aber ich kann doch gar nicht demonstrant sein weil ich war ja gerade bei starbucks.
Weil das also weil sie als starbucks quasi der lizenz nehmendes francis ist quasi so eine mailand company.
Aber diesen ganzen also den relativ kurzen moment das fand ich aber irre interessant so also zum einen okay die haben nichts dagegen wenn man sich das anguckt und selbst wie sie sich umziehen also sagen ja das geheimnis der sache oder so,
aber offensichtlich gar keine berührungsängste.
Ging glaube ich im wesentlichen darum das zu tun wo keine überwachungskameras sind und das sind dann die seitenstraßen.
Aber ich fand 's trotzdem interessant dass sie halt offensichtlich kein kummer hatten dass so ein offensichtlicher fremder beobachter sich das wieso der gaffer anguckt so was macht ihr hier also auch nicht dass es heißt das geht nicht weil das ist sozusagen das geheimnis wie wir rauskommen,
sondern irgendwie.
Also ich fand es sehr diese diese ganze situation von anfang bis ende irgendwie merkwürdig was man dabei gesehen hat was irre war bei dieser hohen grad an organisiert halt also das war halt nicht so ein chaos von deppen die irgendwie kreuz und quer rumrennen,
sondern man merkte immer so das ging immer in eine richtung auf eine kreuzung zum beispiel.
Die einstand rum also hatten so funkgerät mit knopf im ohr und haben die gegend geguckt.
Andere haben zum beispiel mit langen rohren die ampeln kaputt gemacht und hatten dabei aber so wie sie reform gesicht dass sie die splitter nicht abbekommen und handschuhe an und einer der es ohne,
eine brille versucht hat dem haben sie irgendwie gesagt oder klar gemacht er soll das nicht machen weil er die splitter abkriegt also so selbst beim ampeln zentrum auf arbeitsschutz achten das,
also das dir nichts passiert und dieses ganze also organisierte und strukturierte und so das fand ich sehr spannend,
weil das ja auch so ein so ein großer teil oder so dieser sache dort ist also diese technik beziehung,
akkuschrauber bei haben um so straßen schilder oder so diese fußgänger leipzig in rekordzeit zu zerlegen und für barrikaden zu benutzen.
Das soll man überall ne diese ganzen auseinander geschroteten seiten teile die,
glaub ich aus zwei gründen abgeschraubt wurden erstens waren sie natürlich wunderbares barrikaden material weil,
also es ist immer so anderthalb meter abstand solche metall gitter relativ einfach gebaut und dann eben am akkuschrauber relativ leicht zu demontieren die stehen,
du bist auf allen habe ich die sehr oft gesehen entlang der größeren straßen immer so ein längeren blogs um einfach die leute davon abzuhalten den verkehr zu gehen umso dramatisch stellen abzusichern et cetera und,
die war dann irgendwie alle entfernt so dass nur noch diese stände heraus standen lass ich mir so okay erstens ist barrikaden material zweitens erlaubt das natürlich auch aber auf einmal ganz andere fluchtwege,
und die fehlten einfach gefühlt fast überall.
Und also stattdessen war ja oft dieses orangene flattert band dazwischen,
oder an einigen stellen an einigen dann schon wieder abgerissen oder so aber da ich auch gemerkt dieses flattert band also was wo man weiß hier fehlt was ihr war vor was anderes das hat man ja wirklich alle paar meter überall gesehen.
Also diese ganze diese diese resistance techno resistenz also das das hat ja wirklich viele.
Nuancen,
das hat man in der berichterstattung auch schon gesehen allen voran natürlich diese neutralisiert übung von tränengas granaten da gab's ja die verschiedensten strategien glaube was als erstes so richtig umging war so diese
chemische neutralisiert wo ich mir immer noch nicht ganz so sicher bin auf welcher art und weise dass man eigentlich stattgefunden hat auf jeden fall hat man immer eine flüssigkeit
dabei die berichte wasser jetzt wirklich effektiv funktioniert keine ahnung wahrscheinlich,
chemiker reden irgendwie äh auf jeden fall diese strategie die dinger,
nicht einfach so oh gott reizgas granate alle weg wir haben keine chance mehr sondern dass man dem sich halt quasi auch mit einer lösung entgegenstellen sagt okay wir organisieren und jetzt einfach,
und teilweise mit drei vier fünf abgesprochen leuten einheit um ihn einmal dabei mit der flüssigkeit einer sammelt ein anderer steht aber im laub bläser daneben und bläst solange den den rauch weg bis sozusagen diese neutralisiert,
gefunden hat oder was vorhin arbeitest das war aber nicht in hongkong ne das teilweise dinge also tennisschläger zurück geschlagen wurden.
Also in bagdad gab es zwei richtig geile bilder so aus der letzten zeit zum einen granate kommen mit dem tennisschläger da sie haben dann in so einem forum gesagt schläger sind besser wegen der harten verspannung brauchst irre gutes timing.
Ja das kann ich mir gut vorstellen ja.
Was mir noch ein viel was jetzt nicht so gut.
Also wenn man spielt glaube ich hat man das timing.
Aber es ist schon wo ich dachte das sieht geil aus,
und noch ein anderer punkt der aber nicht so skaliert für andere länder die polizei in bagdad hat vor drei vier tagen angefangen hunde einzusetzen und da gibt's halt die schöne video wo dann ein demonstrant mit seinem löwen kam.
Beim löwen okay.
Mit dem löwen an alleine die hunde waren weg.
Wahrscheinlich nicht nur die hunde.
Schau dachte er ist immer einer größer als du ne.
Der löwe.
Was ein in der gegend nicht so wundert die haben ja zum teil so obs google haustiere weil sie es geil finden oder so aber den wir zur demo bringen möchte ich ok das habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Oh man.
Ja aber da ich auch gedacht so wer die leute gucken ja auch im,
der welt wie man es macht also es gibt ja inzwischen genug konflikt gegen den.
Was ich aber in hongkong so interessant fand eigentlich alles was sie tun ist ja kein hexenwerk
also wie man klar oder hc neutralisiert theoretisch kannst du es in der schule lernen also wahrscheinlich hatten wir das alle so im groben und haben's wieder vergessen so wenn's eine lage lage ist brauchst halt irgendwie eine säure und umgekehrt und irgendwie so kam,
das ist ja nichts ist jetzt nicht spezial wissen oder irgendwie rockets sein,
oder auch wenn was angeflogen kommt kannst du es mit dem tennisschläger zurückspielen auch klar also so aber sie nutzen es halt alles zusammen,
im prinzip kann man sagen ja gutes bildungssystem die haben 'ne menge gelernt in der schule und jetzt wenn sie einfach an physik chemie organisieren sozialkunde.
Falls noch mal einer fragt wofür man das leben so brauchen.
Gibts genug möglichkeiten.
Genau und vor allem unsere technologie welt hat ja irgendwie auch noch eine ganze menge andere reaktionen die man glaube ich so auch nicht so sieht man es fängt ja schon mit den atem masken
an dir in asien ohnehin so ein
ein gewisser standard sind weil es da ja,
generell in der kultur verankert ist es wenn man in irgendeiner form niest oder sonst wie irgendwie atemwegserkrankungen hat dann läuft man halt sowieso schon mal mit einem mundschutz rum den wir halt eigentlich so nur aus,
saal kennen oder wenn halt irgendwelche chinesen hier gerade rumlaufen die sich.
Auch wegen saß und so also diese verschiedenen krippen und solide in hongkong hatten also so also jetzt jetzt nicht richtige fette artenschutz muss mal genauso gut so einfache.
Einfach nur so tröpfchen infektionen einfangen so genau das das ist also standard und die gibt es mittlerweile auch in schick so also.
Mit gesichtern drauf oder ein seriös oder.
Ja und schwarz vor allem so speziell bist gespannt also das war richtig.
Also da gibt's richtig designer modelle also so so wie man sich irgendwie wahrscheinlich heutzutage um sein brillen modell viel gedanken macht wie man halt auch mit der richtigen atemschutzmaske unterwegs sein weil wir zum laufen muss man nicht die ganze zeit aussehen wie so ein arzt,
so das geht auch und das passt natürlich dann wunderbar eben in dieser grill ja kultur mit rein weil dann sozusagen wirklich von oben bis unten auch alles schwarz ist teilweise ist natürlich auch der motorrad bedarf
der da ganz gut zu arbeiten das ist ja schon gesagt so protektoren et cetera also man kann sich wirklich eine ganze menge rausholen,
aber es geht ja noch noch weiter mit entsprechenden schutz masken
fürs gesicht etcetera und ja wenn man sich gerade so die bilder der letzten tage angeschaut hat da ist da in der hinsicht sehr viel passive
sehr viel passive aufrüstung.
Betrieben worden dazu kam dann noch so sachen wie laser da gab's ja dann auch mittlerweile interessante übersprungen effekte zu den protesten in chile die ja auch immer noch am dampfen sind,
gab es nur ein paar bemerkenswerte szenen wo so drohnen mit lasern,
runtergeholt wurden und das letztlich auch eine schon letzte woche war.
Besprochen weil leser da sowieso das thema war mit einem starken laser.
Kann man moderne elektronik schon ordentlich schaden,
fügen und zwar nicht so sehr wie man das so star wars,
leser schwert mäßig klar also richtige hochleistungslöschgeräte die,
natürlich 'ne ganze menge energie und können dann halt auch wirklich thermisch,
richtig probleme bereiten aber allein das blenden an sich ist schon mal so ein faktor also teilweise haben die protestler in hongkong dann halt größere tracks einfach die fahrer geblendet,
und wie man immer in diesem drohen beispiel in chile gesehen hat offenbar kann man eben auch diese cd kameras tausendfach verboten,
kann man einfach weg blenden und und und fehler erzeugen oder eben auch komplett außer betrieb nehmen.
Und ich hatte so einen eindruck das kam jetzt auch im zunehmenden maße zum einsatz also alles was sozusagen der hardware store angebot hat wo man sonst schöne sachen mitmachen kann wurde jetzt hier zur zur revolution ausrüstung.
Ja nur dort noch alles was wir hier irgendwie bei aliexpress oder so kompliziert durch den zoll schleusen müssen ist da eine bahnstation weg in schengen also ich glaube
das macht es halt nicht einfacher für die behörden vor ort also alles was wir hier sehen und sagen ah das kann ich eh nicht bestellen weil das bleibt im zoll hängen können die sagen ah ich geben rüber in kauf fünf stück von.
Kaufen sich das in mailand china uns danach gegen die schergen von china zum einsatz zu bringen.
Kapitalismus halt ne.
Ja was auch noch in diesem techno resistenz modus reinkommt dann ging 's halt weiter mit bogen schützen.
Ganz ordentliche bögen nicht so kinder bögen sondern ordentlicher match kram.
Genau gab es ja auch bilder von einem verletzten.
Herr polizist mit dem pfeilen beißen.
Ja
Also da geht's richtig zur sache wo bei dir jetzt nicht die bögen primär glaube ich benutzt haben um leute zu beschließen das mag,
auch stattgefunden haben aber es gab dann so auch ausgefallene strategien mit molotowcocktails also dass das.
In brand schießen.
Sozusagen mit bögen molotowcocktails das normale werfen ist jetzt out ja man macht das jetzt irgendwie so was,
bei den bei dem kampf um die universität zu der wäre sicherlich gleich noch kommen dann auch nochmal eine große rolle gespielt,
hat oder ein bisschen anscheinend macht der ganze straßen kampf.
Wurde er dann auch mit steinen gemacht aber nicht so primär um leute zu bewerfen sondern einfach um die straßen,
unbequeme bar und.
Ja und auch befahrbar also dass man drüber stolpern und auch also beides weil ich dachte so normale ziegelsteine fährt man mit dem auto halt drüber also.
Ich bin ja selber amor security drive weiß ich bin ausgebildet um in so gegen den also in krisengebieten gepanzerten fahrzeuge zu fahren.
Da wäre so ein ziegelstein will mich echt überhaupt nicht drum kümmern also so da fährt man also üblicherweise fahre ich so sechs tonnen schwere land cruiser da rollt man halt drüber.
Dann dachte ich ja okay weil da einer liegt oder zwei aber was ist denn wenn du den tag lang über fünftausend gefahren bist also was ist so was hält so ein reifen heißt na du hast ja not lauf eigenschaften,
ja das ist ja immer für für den notfall also so wenn der reifen platt ist muss ihnen trotzdem tauschen da ich auch gedacht stimmt das ist so auch,
zum beispiel bei einem meiner ausbildung überhaupt kein szenario da ist eine sache auf der straße oder auch fahrt durch ein brennendes auto rampe weg weil du bist ja nachher in der base und es kann repariert werden,
aber der fall von du hast das permanent eine woche lang,
also auch schlichtweg man hat nicht so viel ersatz greifen für ein wasserwerfer oder sowas also klar man kann alles bestellen aber ich glaub nicht dass sie bei sich in der werkstatt ein stapel wasserwerfer ersatz reifen liegen haben weil man die nicht so oft braucht also ab einem gewissen grad.
Ist dann wieder ein logistik problem da gab's ja dann die ersten fotos von wasserwerfern bei dem der reifen quasi von der felge gerutscht ist.
Also wahrscheinlich irgendwie druck verlust entweder ein loch reingeschossen oder
sie haben den der so oft über so kleine steinchen und größere und kanten gefahren bis irgendwie material ermüdung war oder sowas also irgendwie eine kombination aus einem unterm strich kann man sagen die haben in den tag mit wasserwerfer reifen platt gekriegt und da musste erstmal abziehen,
also und das finde ich so spannend weil auch denkt das ist so trivial aber klar so steht da tropfen höhlt den stein und halt wenn man rüber läuft und weggerutscht und sich den irgendwie,
das sprunggelenk zerrt oder so das mag lächerlich kleinkriegen aber der der polizist rennt halt nicht mehr den tag lang.
Ja also.
Interessante strategien die hier gefahren werden und so,
kann dann eben auch noch eine vergleichsweise überschaubare gruppe von leuten hier,
dem staat doch einiges entgegensetzen und.
Ich bin jetzt nicht so begeistert davon klingt das ganze hat natürlich alles die gewisse dramatik zumal es ja eben mit extrem friedlichen proteste angefangen hat wo sie auch die polizei zurückgehalten hat,
und die berichte trudeln nun in zunehmenden maße ein ich habe die erfahrung hast du auch gemacht das halt,
auf eine andere sprache gesprochen wird bei der polizei.
Sogar doppelt also sozusagen metaphorisch dass die aggressiver werden aber auch dass sie auf einmal wir uns ja berichtet wurde mandarin sprachen also das mailand china chinesisch,
wo sie ist komisch du kommst aus hong kong aber du sprichst die sprache aus made in china ist ja verrückt.
Also da muss man sagen also dort wird ja kein tunesischen gesprochen und katholisch und mandarinen ist zwar in der schrift das gleiche aber der sprache komplett anders.
Und die haben halt gesagt wenn jemand hier als polizist arbeitet.
Und aber mandarin spricht dann wirft das zumindest fragen auf wo der eigentliche herkommt und wenn er dann nicht mal kann tonys richtig versteht dann hat man doch arge zweifel ob der wirklich in hongkong polizist ist oder nicht ein chinesischer oder sogar militär oder so,
und das andere ja diese.
Dieses aggressiver werden oder beziehungsweise ich habe die polizei vorher ja nicht erlebt aber im sinne von sie waren halt nicht präsent also so ähnlich wie in deutschland läuft halt rum und ja irgendwo ist mal irgendwie ein polizist aber du nimmst dir so im alltag nicht,
war oder du interagiert nicht groß mit ihnen und das ist dann ganz schnell gekippt aber so auf,
zwei ebenen also sozusagen dass bei so einer ausschreitungen oder bei so einer demo,
die polizei da ein bisschen angespannt ist denke ich ja das das versteht man noch in gewissen maße also wenn ich hier,
zu einer neonazi demo und zum polizisten und sagt hey ich will da mal durch kann es auch sein dass ich der hundertste binder sagt nee komm hau ab hier ihr grad nicht was er halt wenn ich ihnen im alltag in der shopping treffe nicht sagen würde da wird da sagen hallo wie kann ich dir helfen,
so und da war es halt so das war immer noch der eine abend wo dann diese black clear rumliegen und die polizei kam.
Und ich dachte halt okay alle sind weg also ich sehe wieder diese,
ich sehe ich die trauerveranstaltung der renten bisschen polizei irgendwie rum hieß es haben wir irgendwie gehört ok zeit essen zu gehen so egal.
Und dann das war so bizarr haben wir uns so versucht zu orientieren und dann guckt hinter so einer nach so 'ner beton säule vom übergang halt,
guckte so ein polizist vor mit diesem granat werfer in der hand und verschwand wieder also so wie einmal um die ecke geguckt und dachte ich so okay also der.
Übergang meinst du.
Soll so fußgänger überwiegt.
Da muss man dazu sagen hongkong ist voll davon man hat zwar hohe gebäude viele straßen muss jetzt nicht jedes mal wenn man den block wechselt über die straße rüber sondern es gibt extrem viele viele von diesen flyer.
Genau diese fußgänger brücken.
Fußgänger brücken die sind überall im stadtbild zu sehen.
Genau und das war so also der guckte sofort war wieder weg will ich zumindest mal gucken also so wo der herkommt gibt's doch mehr und vielleicht reicht's ja soviel weißt du so ein lustiges bild so hoch geröstete polizisten also einfach so,
also nicht mal groß drüber nachgedacht da dachte ich verwende um die ecke gucken will ich mal gucken was um die andere seite so ist und ähm ja.
Als ich da um die ecke geguckt habe kann da noch ich weiß nicht zehn zwanzig von seinen kumpels,
ganz mit diesen granat werfen und alle mit gasmaske auf und den helm und also so zeug was man in deutschland echt
selten sieht also zumindest polizist mit gas massen sind in deutschland schon eine,
age seltenheit würde ich mal sagen aber dann noch dass der eine punkt kann hat der nächste granat werfer und noch einer irgendwie in beiden händen so ein liter pfefferspray das ist so irgendwie das ist mir hier echt noch nicht begegnet.
Und.
Wo war das jetzt genau.
Das war in zum west also da wo ich das hotel hatte da so in der.
Im norden.
Im norden so relativ also sozusagen dass das nördliche ende vom vom metro system würde ich so so meine also da kommt danach kommt so hügel und.
Da kommt nicht mehr viel dann kommt auch so ein bisschen ländlicher e fläche und das ist auch schon irgendwann wieder.
Schenken sie genau.
Und wir schieben das also so eine so eine wohnung gegenteil sonne nicht zu teure oder so da gibt's halt so große gebäude und.
Diese polizisten rannten dann auf also so quasi als ich um die ecke guckte alle los über diese fußgängerbrücke,
dann hab ich gedacht mal hinterhergehen weil die werden ja irgendwo hin rennen also so neugierig bin ich dann ja doch,
und als ich dann aber los gerannt bin.
Hat sich halt einer umgedreht und so mit dem schlagstock gedroht und kam auf mich zu wo ich dachte ja okay das hab ich verstanden du magst nicht und der dahinter begriff aber ins holzer anzug den revolver die haben so uralte galligen dienst gewollt war.
Dann kam aber also auch andere leute und haben halt geguckt was die machen und steckte den einfach wieder so ein,
ich dachte okay der würde mich jetzt hier nicht ab knallen oder so aber zumindest so nun eine deutliche droht kulisse einfach nur weil man guckt was die machen also so ohne.
Ohne dass man auch nur im geringsten gefährlich wäre oder so und da hab ich gedacht das ist zumindest,
sag mal eine deutlich aggressiv und deutlich komisch vom vom gesamten erscheinungsbild her also
ohne dass ich ihnen jetzt irgendwie zwei meter auf die pelle gerückt wäre oder ohne dass ich irgendwie sozusagen aggressiv hingegen aufgetreten bin so ich habe halt einfach nur wissen gekauft was sie da so machen.
Und da dachte ich dann auch okay dann lieber ein bisschen abstand halten weil das kann man halt nicht einschätzen wie sie drauf sind oder wie nicht,
und das wird in den nächsten tagen aber immer immer mehr so ein derart also das mir schienen dass die immer aggressiver wurden.
Und aber so völlig zweigeteilt also manchmal liefen die soll dieser ganzen ausrüstung einfach direkt vor meiner nase her weil sie irgendwie von rechts nach links gelaufen sind,
kann sich überhaupt nicht drum gekümmert ob man sie filmt oder was man macht und im nächsten moment kam welche und haben einem verbieten wollen dass man fotos macht und haben ein,
mit mit dem camp koran diese bei haben,
gefilmt und wollt dass man sich ausweist und so also so und das innerhalb von einer minute beides also das fand ich halt so wie.
So dass man es nicht einschätzen kann also dass das so hin und her springt,
und ich weiß nicht ob die leute vor ort das besser einschätzen können oder verstehen aber für mich war das so völlig willkürlich und unverständlich wie das,
also warum ist es jetzt so und dann so und der ist nochmal anders.
Wir sind jetzt an welchem tag sind wir jetzt angekommen von der.
Immer noch freitagabend.
Immer noch freitagabend das heißt eigentlich so richtig was passiert ist jetzt noch nicht also so richtig kämpfe in dem sinne hast du nicht gesehen aber alle haben irgendwie so mehr stellung bezogen das ist eigentlich das ding.
Genau und da war,
also es ist erstmal direkt dass ich diesen heftigen tränengas tränengas einsatz mitbekommen habe oder wie später gemerkt habe das war noch gar nicht so heftig dass es ging mir nur da sehr viele hab ich ja später gemerkt da geht's noch ganz anders ab,
also irgendwie da waren verhältnismäßig wenig polizisten und viele sagen wir so demonstranten von vermuten bis unverblümt und alles aber so,
ich würd mal so ganz grob schätzen fünfmal so viele leute die gegen die polizei waren die polizisten oder so und.
Denn gut so polizei taktik ist ja auch irgendwie jetzt nicht das große geheimnis dann machst du halt show force und irgendwie verjagt die leute ein bisschen und irgendwie zeigt so dass du du stärker bist okay,
aber das kann ich eigentlich das was wirklich wie so eine machtdemonstration halt ist und dann guckt man erstmal wer geht.
Und die haben aber halt auch direkt mit den waffen als auch mit diesem pump ganz also die können sie könnten mit schrott oder projektieren geladen sein was da war wohl kaum der fall war du kannst aber auch sowas wie,
na wieso plastik kugeln mit verschießen die einfach irre wehtun also wieso gummi geschossen oder,
auch sowas wie kleine gast kanada also klein gart kam also
das problem ist wenn du halt in die mündung guckst weißt du halt nicht was auf dem auf der anderen seite ist und nur weil es wahrscheinlich ist dass da gummiball rauskommen die nur sehr wehtun ist das immer noch unangenehm wenn der typ in der pampa an vor einem steht ne,
oder auch mit diesem granat wer von 'ner achtunddreißig millimeter werfen man sagt ja die.
Die werden hier schon keine granaten schießen aber auch diese gast kanada will man nicht abbekommen also es macht 's bedingt besser,
also ich fand das zum teil lustig bei so facebook kommentaren wenn leute gesagt haben ja es sind ja nur gas kanada sagt ja alles klar dann stell dich mal davor und ich drücke ab gucken ob wir immer noch so granate.
Ja weil die sind ja nicht aus sondern es sind ja irgendwie auch metallteile irgendwie.
Also immer wenn man so eine granate unglücklich vom kopf kriegt kann man auch tot sein also es halt weil einfach energie hinter.
Und schlichtweg so das wird nicht so aufstand bekämpfung benutzt weil so gut zu atmen ist ne also das.
Also deswegen dachte ich schon ja es war schon also die haben dann bisschen reizgas eingesetzt haben so ein paar granaten verschossen das war,
in summe zudem was ich dann die nächsten tage erlebt habe überhaupt nicht viel aber überhaupt so dieses brennende zeug dann abkriegen,
ich hab mich halt gewundert weil ich dachte ich habe gar nicht viel von abgekriegt.
Und ich kenne es sonst so dass also wenn man gewissen abstand hat dann brennt das halt und die augen drehen und das ist so wie wenn man zu viel chili gefressen hat oder sollte so echt unangenehm und dann muss man halt einfach nichts tun und warten oder halt ausspülen.
Nicht augen reiben nicht kratzen oder so und abwarten aber so dass so im bereich von sehr unangenehm aber mehr nicht.
Und da war es halt so von sozusagen den bisschen was der wind so rüber getragen hat also wann sagte ja so am rande wo man jetzt ein paar meter weggeht und sich einmal die augen aus wäscht,
habe ich sofort 'n tierischen husten anfall gekriegt und die augen haben so getrennt dass ich überhaupt nichts mehr gesehen hab.
Dachte ich erst okay vielleicht bin ich ein bisschen aus der übung und hab's falsch eingeschätzt wird richtig dran bin oder so.
Da war auch wieder der grad an organisiert hat also mich hat sofort jemand gepackt aber der hat nicht irgendwie so am ärmel gezündet oder so und mich so un koordiniert irgendwohin gezogen,
sondern der hat mich am handgelenk und an der schulter gefasst und sozusagen,
seine hand auf meiner schulter und den arm auf dem rücken so dass er mich richtig geführt hat in der richtung,
denkt das ist jetzt auch kein großes geheimnis aber der hat offensichtlich erfahrung wie führst du leute die selber nicht sehen also wie bringst du ihn korrekt in die richtige richtung dass er weiß da jetzt lang und hoch oder runter.
Okay das irgendwie also irgendwo muss erstmal gesehen oder gelernt haben es ist trotzdem wieder anders so ne.
Ich hab mich da irgendwie rausgezogen und dann haben sie mir irgendwas ins gesicht halt auch gehauen also wahrscheinlich was einfach wasser oder so in dem fall weil ich so viel nicht abgekriegt hab und dann wird so stück für stück besser also so war so.
Also überschaubar ich dachte trotzdem für das bisschen was ich abgekriegt haben relativ heftig so vom effekt her.
Und ich hatte vor gehört dass die da viel schlimmeres und viel wildere reizgas einsetzen aber die story gibt's immer und überall,
also das ist so jeder sagt immer ne die haben hier spezial militär kram und die mischen da irgendwas bei und man sagt ja ja ich weiß.
Und da dachte ich gut zum einen sind das irgendwie kräfte aus china den traue ich sowas deutlich eher zu,
also es gab ja auch hier so gerüchte die polizei hat bei zwanzig b eingesetzt und sowas,
und die argumentation war das einzelne inhaltsstoffe von zyklen b auch in c s gas ist das war eine ganz lange argumentation kette wo ich dachte er deswegen ist man da so sehr sagt man ja komm die stories kennen wir alle.
Geht zwanzig mal jetzt die proteste.
Genau hier in in hamburg genau und deswegen halt habe ich den nicht so viel bei gemessen und dann hab ich aber dann nochmal genauer gefragt,
und da gibt's fernsehsender die haben zum beispiel proben genommen oder das gemessen.
Man sagt ja da ist so ein gewisser blau säure anteil oder so drin und die sozusagen die menge an klar und solchen stoffen die drin ist einfach viel viel höher als das was man hier so in deutschland gewohnt ist,
er sagt okay das das ergibt sinn.
Weil der nebel also was ich in den nächsten tagen gesehen hab viel viel dichter ist also hier kann ich es wenn so reizgas eingesetzt wird dann hast du so,
na wie halt so ein bisschen nebel und bei dem was wirklich wie so eine weiße wand wo du überhaupt nichts mehr durchgesehen hast schon bei einer granat oder sollte wirklich wie so eine rauchgranate oder so,
und ich dachte auch okay so wie schnell man dann merkt okay das ist jedoch ganz anders und es.
Dadurch habe ich auch verstanden warum das so viel schneller eskaliert,
weil wenn hier in deutschland so reizgas also erstmal grad granaten schießen in deutschland ja fast nie also es ist echt 'ne super ausnahme aber das ist ja nicht alltag hier das,
irgendwie die polizei berlin bei einer demo mal hundert granaten rein schießt oder sowas und meist eben hier diese diese sprayer die so fünf sechs meter gehen.
Wo man halbwegs genau mit treffen kann also die person rechts und links kriegt 's mal ab aber halt nicht dass man einfach mal die demo ein nebel und nachher guckt wer noch da liegt.
Da eben gezielt einzelne leute quasi auch.
Zumindest wo man sagt naja man versteht zumindest die begründung warum er geschossen hat ob er den richtigen getroffen hat und alles okay darüber was man streiten,
aber es ist nicht lass mal die demo flach ballern und dann gucken was passiert ist also dann sagt er schon unterschied,
deswegen wenn hier in deutschland sei es wenn wir wird reizgas eingesetzt denke ich mir meine güte gehe ich fünf schritte zurück und dreh mich um,
und wenn ich nicht gerade neben jemandem steht der was geworfen hat oder so oder in der ganz falschen ecke stehst die chance dass ich was abgekriegt sehr gering,
also das ist einfach meine erfahrung aus der praxis hier in deutschland habe ich glaube ich nie reizgas von polizisten abgekriegt,
weil man einfach immer das tiere möglichkeit hat dem aus dem weg zu gehen.
Und dort halt nicht also ich dachte okay das ist der große unterschied also sehr,
an dem entgehen will und selbst wenn man abstand hält.
Ist die chance was ab zu kriegen trotzdem sehr sehr hoch und da kann ich auch verstehen dass man damit.
Mehr probleme mit der bevölkerung hat also wenn man meinen in deutschland so den durchschnittlichen menschen fragt wer kriegt denn hier polizeigewalt ab,
dann ist glaube ich die alle häufigste antwort na der muss ja was gemacht haben der wird ja also sie,
polizei tut ja sonst nichts irgendwie irgendwas muss ja vorgefallen sein so,
zumindest so als herrschenden meinung,
und in hongkong hab ich halt reihenweise gehört so ja das pech gehabt also so du musst nicht mal annähernd in der falschen gegen gewesen was einfach pech gehabt dass der polizisten schlechten tag hatte,
und das so als eine häufige meinung von so durchschnittlichen leuten im cafe oder so,
dachte okay das ist natürlich auch schlecht für den ganzen konflikt wenn so die sah war die grundlagen nahmen der großen bevölkerung schonmal ist die polizei ist schlecht also ist das fördert die sache nicht.
Und was ich da auch spannend fand an dem abend als dann die ersten leute kam die so mit reizgas und so da lang geschleppt wurden neben mir.
Kam auch aus dem ganzen läden und so leute mit so wasser einmal also so ein zehn liter einmal voll wasser einfach oder so die das halt gebracht haben zum helfen ich dachte aber so mir schienen die unterstützung von den normalen menschen die da irgendwie arbeiten oder leben
für die demonstranten war schon,
ziemlich hoch also so mir wurde was gesagt von fünfundsiebzig prozent kann man halt ganz schwer,
einschätzen also irgendwie gibt keine quelle für die zahl aber zumindest dass viele leute,
einfach mal von sich aus helfen und das unterstützen und nicht einfach ihren laden zu machen und sagen pech gehabt da dachte ich okay das ist auch.
Das ist gut für die die da demonstrieren also dass sie so einen gewissen rückhalt haben und das scheinbar auch überall also ein ein gegner wo ich sowas gesehen hab,
gab's 'ne menge normaler leute die geholfen haben.
Oder eben auch so details als ich die ein vorher umgezogen hatten haben sich ein paar einfach in einem café zu offensichtlich fremden menschen an den tisch gesetzt sozusagen um sich zu tan als die polizei vorbei kam,
und die leute die da saßen haben da überhaupt nichts gemacht nicht kommentiert und halt auch nicht mit dem finger drauf gezeigt und sagt ey die kenne ich nicht sondern so bleiben da halt so sitzt.
Da halt einfach genau.
Dachte das ganze setting also auch dass man sich zu wildfremde hinsetzt da muss man zumindest denken dass man 'ne hohe wahrscheinlichkeit hat dass das funktioniert also so.
Aber das war auch so ein bisschen mein mein eindruck dass du die schweigende mehrheit auf jeden fall da ist nicht jeder sieht jetzt sich dazu in der lage sich da in den straßen kampf zu begeben aber,
gerade diese tränengas einsätze ich meine das findet in einer stadt statt wo,
wir von engen straßen hochhäusern und so weiter umgeben ist also wenn da die tränengas wolke durch die straßen zieht dann zieht das halt auch in die wohnung rein klar wenn man sich versammelt hat klar aber mal hat man auch mal ein fenster auf neue stehen auf dem balkon oder keine ahnung.
Die klimaanlagen vor allem.
Oh ja die klimaanlagen genau das heißt das wird einfach wirklich viele leute auch über dem wege betroffen haben aber ich denke das hat einfach grundsätzlich schon eine
grundstimmung vorherrscht die halt mit diesen vorgängen einfach überhaupt nicht glücklich ist natürlich immer wieder berichte mit ja die stimmungsumschwung und jetzt
ja auch wir alle dagegen sehr schwer das einzuschätzen aus unserer position mit so wenig erfahrung aber ich,
haben wir das ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig vorstellen weil es ist eine fatale tische,
grundstimmung die da jetzt ist weil das hat hier auch im gespräch mit mario six aus hier vor ein paar wochen so das,
eigentlich ja eben klar ist es ist einfach unvermeidlich,
das ist so demokratie die selber den namen vielleicht auch nur so begrenzt verdient aber sagen wir mal so eine rest freiheit mit ablaufdatum,
was er ohnehin nach fünfzig jahren stattfindet also es hält ist halt gerade nochmal,
und das ist jetzt nicht mehr viel das heißt alle jungen leute wissen ganz genau in ihr ihrer lebenszeit ist das ding halt durch und jetzt die zeit so aus als ob es einfach vorgezogen wird.
Ja und weil ich halt auch denke wenn ich jetzt wieder den vergleich zu deutschlands hier,
wenn ich mich hier zu wildfremde ins café setze ich glaube egal wie die situation ist erstmal gibts theater das wäre so meine grund annahme also die meisten deutschen fühlen sich ja von allem gestört.
Und also einfach so wenn ich hier von der demo wegrennen und mich zu leuten setze kommt vielleicht drauf an was für welche aber zumindest werde ich schief angeguckt und da dachte ich diese selbstverständlichkeit das ist finde ich der entscheidende unterschied dass so.
Also oder diese routine oder wie man es nennen soll also das offensichtlich alle beteiligten wissen was gerade sache ist.
Einfach einfach mitziehen und vielleicht auch sogar teil dieser ganzen organisation sind weil wenn man sich anschaut wie wie schnell sich diese proteste auch verlagern
schnell sie sich finden alles wird ja das ist ja auch noch mal so ein aspekt dieser techno resistenz so dass man alles bei telegramm abstimmen wo gehen wir jetzt hin oder wo passiert was wo es unterstützung,
fällig wo gehen auch sofort spontan noch mit dazu und helfen den leuten die dann verletzt worden sind.
Und auch diese also diese google karte mit wo bewegt sich die polizei gerade oder das gibt's dann auch in chat form und so ja auch dann genau einfach alles was man so an crowd sourcing möglichkeiten für informationen hat einfach mal nutzen,
dabei.
Ein relativ zuverlässiges ergebnis bringen also weil ich dachte auch wie verhindert man jetzt dass du einfach völlig unter wandert wirst von bergen von trollen oder sowas.
Und das scheint ja aber auch zu funktionieren irgendwie also.
Zumindest das was ich so in den charts und in den karten und so gesehen habt das war,
also alles was ich gesehen habe war zuverlässig also kannst zumindest nicht völlig,
von blödsinn sein und dieses also.
Diese infrastruktur dann schützen während sie offen ist das stelle ich mir halt auch irgendwie schwierig vor oder also irgendwie es funktioniert ja aber schreit ja danach missbrauch zu werden oder überlaufen zu werden.
So jetzt bist du äh ja obwohl er eigentlich nur ein vortrag halten wolltest und der war die stadt anschauen wollt dann doch wieder so in so eine presse kriegst berichterstattung modus gekommen,
ist das jetzt um dich herum da noch weiter eskaliert also was er dann ganz fleißig,
getwittert auch irgendwie fotos geschickt und ich saß da jetzt wieder zu hause hatten wir so.
Ein tag zu früh abgereist.
Den spaß hätte ich auch haben können so wollte ich unbedingt mal tränengas aus.
Ähm ja du bist ja auch recht geladen los und du hast ja dann so auch einiges bietet auch einiges fotografiert.
Das fiel dann auf.
Ja ich glaube schon also ich hab das war vor allem am nächsten tag ging 's wieder weiter mit erstmal programm bei tagsüber war wieder nichts los also ich fand auch spannend wieder so hin und her,
schwappt und ich hatte dann also ich habe mich wie immer einfach viel mit leuten unterhalten.
Ich hatte auch also ich hatte eine ordentliche kamera bei und viele da sind aber fotoscheu weil die sagen es geht nicht nur um das foto jetzt,
aber wenn in fünf jahren das foto durch irgendeine bilderkennung läuft oder ein zehn,
habe ich den gleichen ärger also die verstehen wie technik funktioniert,
teilzeit okay wenn ich eh wenig fotos machen kann also nur so sehr bedingt.
Kann ich dir auch ab und zu mit dem handy machen und dann halt umso mehr mit leuten sprechen um erstmal zu verstehen was ist hier los,
dann fand ich ganz interessant weil die leute mich halt gefragt haben na wie ist denn das hier im vergleich zu deutschland oder zu kurdistan oder so,
ich dachte naja es ist halt alles anders als in deutschland man sagen also,
so fast alles was wir hier an polizei einsetzen haben es einfach mal harmlos gegen das was man dort sieht also zumindest so die breite masse,
und kurdistan hat es halt also am rande davon dass es ein kriegsgebiet das kann man nicht vergleichen.
Aber was ich dann ganz interessant fand dass mir leute halt erklärt haben ja.
Sie belastet das psychisch sehr stark dass sie permanent angst haben dass ihn,
also ja nicht nur auf der demo sondern du gehst nach hause und du weißt nicht kommt die polizei,
ich wollte dich einfach ab weil irgendein grund haben sie schon,
und selbst wenn nicht dann lassen sie sich halt am nächsten tag gehen aber dann hast du trotzdem die nacht bei denen verbracht oder so also so irgendwie dieses ungewisse und.
Auch dass er hat gesagt haben sie können ja nirgends hin wo es sicher ist sie können nicht einfach ausreisen siebten also wenn die administration gegen dich ist dann hast du halt keinen sicheren fleck mehr und halt auch psychisch nicht also nicht dass du mal entspannen kannst,
sagt das glaube ich dass das sehr belastend ist hatte das aber auch nach dem ersten abend gemerkt,
dass ich halt auch dachte in kurdistan also egal wo wir waren und was los war im zweifel bist du ein zwei stunden gefahren und was in der sicheren gegend und kostet in irgendein hotel gepackt oder in die base und bist in die wanne gegangen und hast irgendwie filme geguckt und konntest abspannen,
und du wusstest hier bin ich sicher weil hier gibt's pressefreiheit gibt gewissen maß an demokratie und hier sicher.
Und wenn du das nicht nur wie ich da so ein zwei tage in hongkong dann hast und allein die einreise nach hongkong auch wenn's 'ne china ist ich habe da immer schon schlechtes gewissen so was ist mit meiner i ist das alles sicher hier,
ist das hotelzimmer irgendwie sicher wie viel wird ja abgehört oder sonst was.
War sicherheit in anderen gegenden nicht hab aber zu den chinesen glaube ich traut man da aus der erfahrung eine menge zu,
inwiefern die ihre sachen in hongkong ausgerollt haben es halt unklar.
Also umgekehrt ich würde nicht sagen in hongkong bin ich total sicher weil das ist ja eine china also so das ist ja auch lange vorbei und.
Das fand ich dann aber ganz interessant weil ich dachte stimmt also so diese diese psychische belastungen die ich sonst in anderen gegenden hab.
Die habe ich da so kurzfristig und ich kann mich der jederzeit entziehen also ich kann einfach sagen jetzt habe ich keinen bock mehr jetzt gehe ich hier aus dem gefährlichen bereich,
auch hier in deutschland denke ich wenn man auf so so nazi-demos oder so ist,
das kann in dem moment sehr anstrengend sein und dann fährst du halt mit der u-bahn zwei stationen und setzt sich ins café und das überhaupt nichts mehr aber du du bist nicht zwingend der sache ausgesetzt.
Und dann.
Also in berlin zumindest.
Ja genau also.
Gibt es schon so orte in ost-berlin aus deutschland da würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen dass so ohne weiteres rückzugsorte findest.
Aber da selbst da könntest du nach berlin fahren oder so also du hast so eine ne du du hast irgendwie eine möglichkeit dich dem zu entziehen,
ohne irgendwie dein leben abzubrechen oder so ne sondern also so,
und das fand ich ganz interessant weil man also ich glaub die allermeisten menschen in deutschland wohnen können das überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen weil sie so situationen gar nicht kennen also du hast hier diese belastung nicht,
und
die leute auf twitter oder gerade auf twitter merke ich dann immer wieder wie die leute meinen dass es hier genauso wie in china weil sie haben nicht ihr liebling sneakers vor hinbekommen und da sind sie jetzt drei tage psychisch hart belastet aber so unterm strich ey hier kennt
kaum einer das gefühl würde ich mal sagen also und vor allem nicht jemand der das land nicht verlassen hat also klar wenn du,
irgendwo wohnzimmer überall neonazis sind und du bist der linke klar dann hast du da ein eindruck von aber das sind eben wenig leute der durchschnitt hier kennt das nicht ich glaube dann ist.
Bitte ausnahme von etwas intensiveren ddr erfahren.
Genau also die genau das halt von früher dann also sozusagen aber sozusagen jetzt jemand der heute zwanzig ist und in deutschland da die allermeisten leute die.
Sehr leidensdruck noch nicht so groß.
Wir wissen nicht genau wo ich denke ist auch prima ist ja wunderbar aber das finde ich ist dadurch immer so schwierig zu vermitteln wie sowas,
also wie ein das so unterschwellig stresst einfach die ganze zeit und.
Darf ich auch auf twitter angeschrieben hier also das ist ein,
aus meiner sicht ein interessanter unterschied dass ich mich halt hier von der hongkong der polizei vielmehr so.
Also vor dieser nicht einschätzen verkeilt der lage und wie die reagieren das ist halt viel wilder als das was der es macht wo ich weiß das sind die terroristen und wenn sie mich sehen dann knallen nämlich ab.
Sonst fahr ich halt wieder weg und bin in sicherheit also das ist irgendwie kalkulierbar oder du weißt hier sicher nicht,
und in hongkong ist es so vielleicht vielleicht nicht heute ja morgen nicht dann doch wieder das ist viel viel anstrengender finde ich so für für für den menschen der das erlebt.
Und das hab ich so na ja ich meine ich schreib 'ne menge wenn der tag lang ist auf twitter und der ist dann irgendwie ich glaub,
zehntausend mal oder so rettet worden.
Also bei den vergleich mit kurdistan und so gemacht hast ne.
Und das war irgendwie also muss wahrscheinlich auf ein zwei multiplikatoren getroffen sein so wie das immer ist und dann geht es ab.
Und was ich sehr lustig fand inzwischen gibt's da diverse varianten von dem bild dass ich sage ich habe angst vor den demonstranten weil die haben mich angegriffen und so also es gibt das inzwischen mit allen möglichen sehr interessanten übersetzungen kursiert hast.
Fand ich auch kein spaßig,
und das fand ich aber ganz interessant weil ich dadurch in den nächsten tagen immer wieder von leuten angesprochen wurde die mich,
handhaben ich denke okay der vorteil ist gleich wenn man rote haare hat und in hongkong rumläuft dass die trefferquote schon mal,
so ne ich mein wenn du dir sozusagen anzug anziehst glaube ich kannst du überall dich so zwischen blenden also da muss man sich schon ein paar mal so gesehen haben um dich wieder zu erkennen,
und das merke ich halt immer wieder das kann gut oder schlecht sein meist ist es gut weil die leute sich an mich erinnern sich kein blödsinn gemacht haben aber kann halt so kann halt so
aber fand ich spannend weil dann halt viele leute mit mir ins gespräch kam oder gezielt gesagt haben hey ich hab das und das gesehen oder das und das erlebt und das finde ich wichtig,
das war schon also diese ganzen gespräche waren schon spannend.
Aber du bist ja nicht nur von demonstrierenden angesprochen worden sondern,
haben wir sozusagen auch noch ein paar andere leute wieder fit gelesen.
Das ist ja immer das problem oder zumindest gehe ich von aus dass das der zusammenhang war ich war in der shopping moll und wirklich,
böse absicht wir wollten holen also weil ich dachte wenn ich schon in hongkong bin muss ich auch trinken das gehört irgendwie dazu.
Das war jetzt immer noch in dieser gegend im norden.
Die genau das war auch da irgendwie um das hotel rum sind so drei vier mals oder so da unterm hotel ist sozusagen eine und rechts und links davon sind welche und da sind so irgendwie.
Das sind überall welche.
Genau da sind überall so kleinere also so oder so mittelgroße mord und ja man sagt babel trinken super.
Und das war echt wie wie in so einem schlechten slapstick film oder so also wir sind in die eine mauer gekommen.
Und da war starbucks der war zerschlagen uns also wie einmal so durch randaliert.
Das ist ja oft so gewesen dass das wenn's jetzt aggressionen gegen orte gab betraf fast,
immer mailand company aus china ist der opfer geworden starbucks hat mir schon erwähnt also die zinsen immer etcetera die aus dem emsland kommen.
Genau der lizenz nehmer von starbucks wenn ich es richtig verstanden hab betreibt der auch bestimmte wieso spätes oder so kleine shops also sixty und noch so ein paar sachen da gab es irgendwie solisten und das waren halt auch genau die shops die ich regelmäßig kaputt gesehen hab,
während der rechts und links nichts abgekriegt hat aber sagen kann ja wirklich zielgerichtet und nicht so blinde randale.
Und bei diesem starbucks hab ich dann halt irgendwie ein foto gemacht und einer von diesem security leuten aus der mal von den ganz normalen der meinte neue leute geht einfach irgendwo anders hin aber hier ist also geht bitte eine andere mal ich glaub nicht dass das hier auf dauer sicher ist so,
es hat okay vielleicht hat er ein bisschen paar neuer vielleicht hat er recht aber im zweifel es gibt eine menge moos drumrum,
trauma dem local also im zweifel.
Aber es wäre so normale security.
Genauso ein ganz normaler typ der auch einfach nur so wie so ein netter hinweis einfach meint hey leute hier da hier gibt's ein bisschen randale und,
so ihr seht aus wie touris schieb mal ab weil manchmal eskaliert das so also einfach wirklich freundlich gemeinsam wollen so zu sichern.
Ja das hatte ich natürlich auch schon als ich ins hotel kam kriegt man dann gleich so ein security briefing ja man sollte lieber nochmal fragen und,
wir haben ja auch unseren shuttle und
wenn ihr wenn es in irgendeiner form euch nicht möglich ist in diesem shuttle zu gehen hier sind die hotels wo ja jederzeit reingehen könnt et cetera also jeder hat sich schon so gewisse so notfall pläne bereit gelegt ja natürlich den touristen dann auch,
verboten werden wo man halt auch denkt so ja okay.
Denkt ja das das kenn ich so als ich in den collagen höhn war im hotel da hab ich so so ein briefing bekommen da ist der bunker und hier steht ein auto aber dachte auch so nicht in hongkong,
und dann halt in die nächste mal rüber und als ich nur die maul rein ging,
flog irgendwie draußen so alle also von draußen in die mal so 'ne reizgas granate,
und ich habe aber nicht gesehen warum also so da also es gab nichts woran ich es aus also da war nicht mal jemanden schwarzen klamotten oder so.
Aber in die shopping wohl selber rein.
Und ähm,
so reizgas abgekriegt versorgt worden das gleiche wie irgendwie ein zwei tage vorher in die nächste mal weil ich dachte wenn sie die eine aus räuchern wird die andere ja gerade sicher sein.
Und da liefen dann diese also richtig also es gibt auch zwischen diesem sozusagen schwer bewaffnete polizisten da noch abstufungen
also man sieht 's an der ausrüstung es gibt so verschiedene wieso der normale streifen polizist der einfach das zeug überzieht und so die die ältere version von der schutzkleidung und gasmaske hat,
und vor allem diesen alten revolver der echt aussieht wie so 'n wild west gewollt war noch also zum teil wohl aus den siebzigern oder so,
und dann gibt's die moderneren einheiten mir wurde dann gesagt die heißen rap dorf oder so werden die genannt,
so die aufstand bekämpfung einheiten die einfach die hochwertigen sachen haben und auch neuere waffen also wo man sieht so die haben von allen das moderne zeug.
Und die stand auf einer von diesen fußgängerbrücke und haben leute durchsucht da da stand dann so zwanzig von diesen typen mit mitteilt pump gans und pistolen und den granat werfen,
und am irgendwie und gasmaske schon auf und allem und haben einfach bei fußgängern die taschen durchsucht also so die die rucksäcke und so,
ja auch dachte so und das kannst du nicht ohne gasmaske und ohne helm oder wie also irgendwie so eine bizarre sache also überhaupt weit und breit nicht zu erkennen was irgendeine gefahr rechtfertigt,
aber diesen ganzen kram an und daneben standen leute sozusagen zivil gekleidet aber mit der gleichen gasmaske und im gleichen helm weil man sieht okay die gehören,
irgendwie dazu aber wenn sie's abziehen sehen sie halt aus wie zivilisten.
Und da waren welche bei die mit so einem concordia gefilmt haben also wirklich jeden einzelnen der vorbei kam in,
ab gefilmt da habe ich dann so ein bisschen von,
gefilmt also so mit dem handy einfach weil ich die also diese szene war so bizarr wieso wirklich so wie alltagssituation leute gehen über die fußgängerbrücke und diese hoch gerösteten typen dazwischen mit null erklärung warum das so passiert.
Und aber so ein das waren so zehn fünfzehn meter abstand oder so also auf dem handy video so eine scheiß distanz aber ich dachte ich will auch nicht dich daran und ich würde sagen hey kommt mal besser ins bild ich sehe euch so schlecht.
Und dieses team was gefilmt hat kam dann auf mich zu und hab mich so aus ein zwei metern entfernung gefilmt wo ich dachte ja ist halt so also zum einen das ergibt wenig sinn zu sagen lasst das mal.
Und zum anderen sollen sie halt machen also was.
Und dann und ich wollte eigentlich wieder in die morgen einfacher dachte jetzt sozusagen wegzugehen wenn sie ein ab film sieht vielleicht auch blöd aus er sagte ich warte jetzt die paar sekunden bis sie den nächsten film und dann bin ich halt in die mal und gut habe ich dann auch gemacht.
Und dann verlegten diese polizisten in die maul rein also einfach ging irgendwie da rein haben da leute kontrolliert und.
Die,
dann war so welche von denen die gefilmt haben haben welche von denen,
in dieser vollen kleidung angesprochen auf mich so gezeigt die ganze zeit und dann irgendwas besprochen auch dachte okay,
kann man sich ja vorstellen die kommen gleich über fragen was was treibst du hier oder wer bist du,
dann kann ich sagen oh ich bin ein doofer touri ich gucke mir euer wundervolles land an und äh eure schöne kleidung und die granaten sind doch aus deutschland toll wir sind exportweltmeister.
Also irgendwie so wie immer hab eine blöde ausrede parat nach der sowas soll schon passieren im zweifel sagen die ja lasst das mal oder blöd oder keine ahnung also so also,
irgendwie dem nicht so viel bei gemessen und die sind dann aber,
auch zu anderen leuten die gefilmt haben also so hinein lesen und sind also haben die richtig angebot und den die handy zum teil aus der hand genommen und wahrscheinlich die videos gelöscht oder so schien mir das,
und irgendwie aber so richtig ago also nicht so dass man hingeht und sagt hallo wir sind die polizei sondern also auf die zugerannt und die angebote und mit den schlag stecken in der hand und so also ich dachte so immer noch warum also was was ist denn passiert,
und dann kam die zu mir dann kam aber jemand der ganz normal uniformierte war also ohne ohne diese schutzkleidung der auch exzellentes englisch sprach und sagte hey wer bist du was machst du hier und ich hab ja gesagt ich bin durch ich habe das nur irgendwie gesehen,
nur ein bisschen gefilmt fand ich komme oder so fand ich interessant.
Und ähm dann besprochen die sich kurz und dann kam ein anderer sagte ne ne wir wissen wer du bist.
Okay also kann sein vielleicht haben wir einfach den tweet gesehen der rum ging oder so also so aber das heißt also es heißt ja auch nichts so ja gut dann müssen wir halt wer ich bin und sagt nö also.
Relativ einfach sofort diese sachen einstellen also nicht nicht film nicht fotos machen nichts dokumentieren und äh.
Wir wollen auch nicht dass du weiter hier bleibst und das dokumentiert.
Ich habe dich irgendwie im namen auch.
Ja die hatten aber ja mein meine daten gesehen also deswegen ist unklar hatten sie die vorher oder nicht also auch.
Also weil du dich ausgewiesen hast ok.
Da denke ich auch das ist auch ein bisschen blöd weil du weißt nicht triffst du da auch sowas wie ein toll sozusagen der das einfach mit jedem zweiten macht oder hat er dich wirklich erkannt also es ist halt so dieses kann halt beide sein aber genau das ist eben das problem und.
Der sagte dann okay meine flugdaten wann ich denn vorab das land zu verlassen und da die sagt man eigentlich halt in der nächsten nacht.
Und dann hat er auch gefragt ob ich den flug dann bestätigt habe also das eingecheckt hab sagt nö also noch nicht.
Er sagt dann ok dann halt einchecken den flug nehmen.
Bis dahin nicht mehr berichten nicht auffallen sozusagen dann haben wir hier kein problem.
Fällst du nochmal auf berichtest du irgendwas dann haben wir ein problem,
so mal sagen okay,
und wieder so es kann sein dass das einfach ein typ war der die nummer durchzieht weil er irgendwie meint bei der hälfte funktioniert vielleicht.
Oder hat er irgendwas zu melden oder also so weiß man halt nicht ne und dann habe ich halt andere journalisten also so die ich kennengelernt hatte so locals gefragt hab gesagt kennt ihr sowas oder passiert was wir sagen ja das also.
So auf allen arten sie haben sowas von deppen die das einfach nur versuchen sie die halt häufiger unterwegs sind haben's aber auch das ein polizist sagt hey du bist,
irgendwie der tim und ich weiß wer du bist und äh ich habe dich im blick oder so also so mit so,
mehr einschüchtern kann man sagt na rechtlich haben sie überhaupt nichts zu melden es herrscht ja pressefreiheit klar also so ein bisschen zumindest.
Aber auf der anderen seite gibt's halt auch niemand wo du dich über die polizei sagen wir ernsthaft beschweren könntest.
Bei der polizei selber.
Genau und.
Deutschland auch so.
Genau er hat sich ja bewährtes system weil ein polizist würde ja nie lügen also können sie dagegen sich selber ermitteln was soll denn passieren,
und.
Wahnsinn hin und her und dann habe ich halt überlegt so so in zwei richtungen zum einen dann bin ich ja erst recht bleiben weil das heißt jetzt wird's interessant das hauptproblem sollte was auch immer passieren haben blödsinn muss jetzt ja nicht mal sein dass man.
Hier der große politische märtyrer wird sondern einfach nur dass der nächste polizist der dich in der demo erkennt ein über brät oder sowas ne.
Also ist es das risiko wert oder nicht also was habe ich davon und was ist sozusagen so die gefahrenabwehr,
sagt eigentlich bin ich eh nur hier weil ich da so reingeraten bin ich hab überhaupt keine schutzausrüstung da also weil ich sie ab alles so ich denke wie geil
ich habe hier die ordentlichen träger masken ich habe alles an körper und helm und so und alles,
ja schön in berlin im lager und dann habe ich halt gedacht ja.
Also ich hab wenig grund hier zu bleiben und jetzt einen guten grund zu gehen.
Und ich hab den flug ja eh also gut den kann man verschieben das geht schon was ich auch überlegt hatte weil ich dachte noch eine woche bleiben also wenn ich jetzt sozusagen bis jetzt geblieben wäre alter da ist ja noch einiges passiert.
Aber eben dieses so dieses unklare und nicht einschätzen können und nicht.
Also nicht sicher sein dass es nicht völlig eskaliert oder dass china einfach sagt hey wir haben die hongkong regierung abgeschafft wir regieren hier weil wir auf der welt will sich beschweren also,
finde ich auch kein weil es heißt ja wie weit können die denn gehen habt ihr neunzehnhundertneunundachtzig mitgekriegt das massaker was genau war die folge für china,
null so also warum ja man kann ja die hongkong regierung nicht abschaffen sagt warum nicht,
also jetzt mal de facto warum nicht wieso er sagt neben mir ist das zu unklar da gehe ich lieber.
Weil es halt so schlecht einzuschätzen ist und weil ich die gegend dort halt nicht kenne und das also,
diese ganze gemengelage das denke ich es auch der unterschied zu kurdistan also in kurdistan wir sind beschossen worden ein fahrzeug ist bei der miene gefahren und so weiter,
sagt man aber das ist alles in dem rahmen den man irgendwie erwartet man hat einen plan was mache ich jetzt,
und man weiß wer das war und warum und wie also so das ist alles irgendwie einschätzt baader bewertet war und das in hongkong war so für mich so irgendwie so im dunkeln stochern und das ist halt das unangenehme daran.
Jetzt äh bist du dann abgereist ne und äh ja jetzt ist das nicht das jetzt zurück eine woche.
Eine woche am montag vor einer ja genau mutter vor einer woche.
Ja und seitdem gibt's,
zur sache hat man so den eindruck also ich meine chronologisch nicht ganz im plan aber es eskalierte dann dahingehend das zunehmenden maße konfrontation stärker wurden und dann auch neue strategien gefahren wurden
diese zwischenzeitlich in kleineren blockaden arten dann,
aus es gab dann eine besetzung einer fußgängerbrücke die
über eine große stadtautobahn führte und zwar genau diejenige,
kurz hinter dieser brücke in den boden für das nämlich die unterführung unter dem
unter dieser straße die ja quasi hongkong island von seinem nördlichen teil den touris trennt.
Das hat mir ja auch,
in der letzten sendung schon erfahren also das ursprüngliche hongkong island ist ja heutzutage eigentlich nur der kleinere teil von hongkong hat so ein paar kleineren inseln noch dran aber im prinzip
es ist eine sehr viel größere fläche im norden noch dran geklatscht die zwei ist auch nicht komplett bewohnt ist weil er eben auch sehr viele berge sind aber,
was du da erwähnt hast und zehn waren und auch der bereich wo ich,
war das äh gehört dann als vorteil dass so eine ganz wichtige lebensader,
ja und dann standen sie da oben irgendwie auf dieser brücke und haben die nicht geräumt haben irgendwie zeug von oben runter geschmissen und da ist dann kein verkehr mehr und ich glaube auch die metro linien waren dann davon,
auch beeindruckt da hab ich jetzt nicht so im detail den überblick auf jeden fall die konfrontation stieg an und außerdem ja,
gab es dann auch zunehmenden maße auseinandersetzungen rund um die universitäten.
Ich glaub ein wichtiger punkt war der montag also letzte woche montag das dem ein,
äh demonstranten bauch geschossen worden von dem polizisten ich glaube das war einfach auch nochmal so ein punkt wo,
also so man hatte vor einem toten der,
wahrscheinlich runtergestürzt ist sozusagen eigenständig auf der flucht also zumindest so sieht's derzeit irgendwie maßgeblich aus
waren zumindest sagen kann ok der ist tot irgendwie wegen der polizei in irgendeiner form aber die haben nicht direkt umgebracht oder also.
Was wenn's nicht ja.
Genau und dann aber,
vor laufender kamera jemandem bauch schließen was einfach nochmal so ein so ein anderer eskalationen punkt ist und ich glaube das war auch also einer so der entscheidenden punkte worum es dann nochmal gekippt ist.
Ja und dann eben was du sagst diese also und ich glaub was der unterschied dann genau weiß ich abgereist bin von.
Eigentlich nur an den wochenenden und in erster linie abends,
zu wochentags und quasi den ganzen tag proteste also so das war schien mir so ein so ein punkt der sich da verändert hat.
Ja und jetzt haben wir die situation dass sich viele studenten dann in,
jetzt fast gesagt der universität,
verschanzt haben ich glaube es war die university of science technology ich bin mir gerade nicht.
Ich habe auch irgendwie
sozusagen in der zeitleiste den überblick verloren wer wann also was ich dann am montag noch mitbekommen habt von der eu an der ich war dass die gesagt haben also die die unis im prinzip,
geschlossen erstmal.
Und nicht nur die sondern auch alle schulen.
Genau und schulen und dann ja auch andere unis und,
kann sagen bei den hatte sich nicht mal jemand groß verschanzt oder susanna gab so diese üblichen proteste sozusagen vor der tür und das hat schon gereicht dass die uni dicht war und selbst die die profis nicht mehr in ihre büros zum arbeiten konnten also.
Man sagt wenn die polizei sozusagen immer sagt wie schützt doch die die leute dort nur da müssen sie doch sicherstellen dass die mitarbeiter ihre büros kommen und arbeiten können sozusagen und nicht dass man die uni zu macht.
Also ich glaub ich nicht wobei ich nicht so pulli technische.
Die poli war dann später genau das war die da war ich halt am.
Ich glaub am sonntag oder am samstag noch weil da nebendran das museum ist also hab ich noch an der pulli vorbeigelaufen.
Dann die university of china oder china university oder wie heißt ja das kind dann irgendwie so von einem zum anderen.
Ja also es ist die politische universität wo diese totale verbarrikadiert stattgefunden hat.
Die auch an diesem straßen tunnel liegt den du grade oder da in der nähe.
Das sind so autobahn die sich da so lang schlängelt und teilweise sind jetzt leute von dort auch geflogen also sieht jetzt gerade zum zeitpunkt wo wir das jetzt hier aufnehmen einfach so aus.
Dass einfach die eskalation sei es der polizei maximal ist der widerstand ist auch maximal also
krasse szenen die sich da abspielen aber die sind halt über müde die haben natürlich
irgendwie keine dauerhaften reserven es sind jetzt schon vier fünftausend leute festgenommen worden wenn man die zahlen glauben darf und die die dort halt noch ausharren na ja die haben halt einfach irgendwann auch gar keine reserven mehr und jetzt versuchen halt viele auch zu fliehen auch da,
wieder interessante organisation ja das dann sozusagen alles über telegram organisiert wird und dann sie sich abgeseilt haben von so einer fußgängerbrücke wo dann unten leute einfach mit motorrädern vorbei kam und die dann einfach weggefahren.
Ja es ging so ich weiß nicht fünf sechs meter hoch denk ich mal war das den videos nach also schon ordentlich und ich vermute das wird deswegen die polizei auch gedacht hat da müssen sie nicht drauf achten weil da kann keiner runterspringen also nicht dass man das richtig gesichert hat.
Ja und da war da wahrscheinlich noch verkehr so.
Genau dann haben die sich halt abgeseilt mit zwei seilen auch nur und ja also so,
also jetzt ja nicht richtig abseilen sondern halt irgendwie das sei runter hangeln.
Und unten halt dieser berg von motorrädern und mopeds und roland die immer cord also immer einer aufgesprungen und,
fahren und es hieß das ungefähr hundert da in innerhalb von minuten halt runter kam,
die polizei hat so aus ein bisschen entfernung wo diese pepper bolz also wieso paintball markieren mit so pfeffer googeln drin geschossen und,
es war auch ein journalist mit auf der brücke der ihre fotos von oben geschossen hat,
und so zwei drei leute die irgendwie ihren stream so gerade eben um die ecke halten konnten und wo man das so gesehen hat aber ich auch dachte er
irgendwie müssen ja alle diese oben und unten zweihundert dreihundert leute gewusst haben dass sie in diesem moment mit deinem teil an dieser stelle sein müssen ne.
Ja
das ist eine interessante frage auch diese berichterstattung also es wurde da extrem viel gestreamt ging auf twitter rum tausend links wo
die chinesische streams waren und teilweise dieselbe situation aus verschiedenen perspektiven übertragen wurde
also so ein mangel an daten lage gab es diesmal nicht so richtig.
Ne und gestern doch gestern abend gab es das fand ich so das ist sozusagen das lustige problem mit streams,
die polizei rückte irgendwo an und dieser pulk von stream den journalisten so zehn zwanzig die so auf halt zusammenhängt,
ran alle so weg also einfach so ein paar meter weg um so eine ecke und da stand gerade jemand den blumen kübel gepinkelt hat der das einmal in jedes land der welt,
wie gut beleuchtet gebraut kasten wurde.
Ich dachte ja also willst du einfach nur in die ecke pinkeln kommt alle rum.
Na ja ich bin bestens revolutionäre berichterstattung noch möglich man stellt sich vor wir hätten es in deutschland so eine situation hätte ja keiner netz oder würde ja dann sozusagen überhaupt nichts ankommen.
Und was ich auch interessant fand,
da halt viele leute das streaming equipment auf so einem richtigen ordentlichen concordia also so eine fernseh berichterstattung kamera so oder so irgendwie zehntausend euro oder so kostet und klein ist und wo man mit du halt richtig sinnvoll filmen und zoom und im dunkeln film kannst,
und was ich in deutschland fast nur kenne dass man entweder mit dem ordentlichen kamera filmt oder mit dem handy streamt,
aber so wirklich ein reporter der mit einer ordentlichen aber streamen den film kamera durch demos läuft glaube ich habe ich hier noch nicht richtig wahrgenommen oder nicht in der menge,
und ich hatte auch vorgestern mit einer redaktion mal gesprochen.
Die fragen zu hongkong hatte ich habe gesagt warum macht ihr sowas in in deutschland nicht also so einfach aus interesse.
Sagt na das equipment ist halt so unglaublich teuer also man sagt nah die kamera kostet doch,
zehn zwanzigtausend teilweise sagt ja weil sonst priming ding kostet doch auch irgendwie zehntausende.
Da ich auch gedacht also wir reden von irgendwie großen öffentlich-rechtlichen da ich ihnen den link geschickt wo man für neunundfünfzig euro so ein auf hart zweihundertfünfundsechzig adapter kriegt,
und da musst du noch also bei dem billigen modell noch die powerbank dranhängen und so weiter und schlecht übersetzte handy app benutzen,
aber für dreihundert euro kriegst du das in okay und für tausend kriegst du sozusagen die kommerzielle lösung mit einem klettverschluss zum dran machen,
vielleicht gemerkt diese gesamte video redaktion also hatte da noch nie von gehört und da ich auch gedacht irgendwie also.
So wieder dieser punkt in hongkong habe ich das halt viel gesehen und weil's eben inzwischen erschwinglich ist,
auch bei leuten die so ausland wieso na wieso blogger oder so also halt nicht ein großes nachrichten studio sondern jemand mit einer günstigen spiegelreflex irgendwie und so ein bisschen getöteten equipment,
und hab gedacht ja das macht ja auch ein riesen unterschied was man auf diesen streams sieht wenn der die kamera irgendwie auf den stromkosten legt und dann erstmal so ist dreihundert millimeter tele aus pferd um irgendwo hinten in der ecke was stabil zu filmen,
und dann wieder weiter rennt was weil auf seinem handy stream überhaupt nicht sehen würdest der so ein bisschen wackelig ist also auch,
auch da einfach so technisch nicht mal das top aktuellste sondern einfach nur so solide technik,
also bei den top aktuell wäre wenn du dir irgendwie eine ordentliche drohne mit mit nachsicht gerät nimmst das kannst du halt auch irgendwie inzwischen führen für wenige tausend euro kaufen.
Das wäre ein ding oder halt wenn man letztes mal als ich meine nachrichtenredaktion gibt eine kamera equipment einfach horrende das geld aus ich habe schon vor.
Vier jahren auf der milli pole auf so 'ner bistums messe in frankreich,
diese granat werfer drohen gesehen die dann die französische polizei gekauft hat das ist irgendwie eine drohne die ich glaube acht neun kilo heben kann also wo du echt 'ne fette kamera mit dem himmel und alles dran setzen kannst.
Und die konnte hundert meter hoch am stromkabel schweben.
Und wenn sie den einsatz hat wirft sich stromkabel ab und fliegt los,
ich dachte wenn du sowas da irgendwo hast du hängst die kamera also die drohne einfach irgendwo auf dem bürogebäude an das hundert meter seil und film solang du kannst,
und in dem moment wo du weiter will schmeiß es kabel ab und hast noch sechzig minuten flug zeit so das das wäre mal,
und nicht mal steht auf der hat das wär vier jahre alte technik oder mindestens vier jahre alte,
was nochmal einen völlig anderen einblick machen würde und wir reden davon ich weiß nicht dreißig vierzigtausend euro passiert aber meine meine kommerzielle filmproduktion ja echt nicht schocken dürfte an eine quält kosten,
also so den privat menschen schon aber so in dem großen bereich ist das ja sagen wir ein normales equipment geld das wundert mich halt immer wie,
wie wir dann hier in deutschland immer noch von diesen kameras die du kaum auf der schulter halten kannst reden und von wissen stream auf dem i phone also so wie irgendwie ich denke wann wann kommen wir denn so im richtigen heute oder so so bleeding technologie an.
Zu fünf fünf drohen im vier castro team und eine davon mit nachsicht gerät und eine wärmebild und da schön umschaltet bar oder so das wäre ja so stand der technik.
Moment mama ordentliche demonstrationen berichterstattung machen könnte.
Und wie und vor allem auch so wenn du mal wirklich aus der luft dann siehst so wie also ich hatte es jetzt bei den spielen schon gesagt hat hat jemand das straßenschild gesehen wo sind die eigentlich inzwischen ah das m donald's gegenüber und die straße ist ungefähr so und so,
auch denk auch so sachen wie diese daten einblenden was ja schon vor jahren auf dem stream ging oder halt mit 'ner,
hoch wie viel leute sind das also so mal den überblick von der straße ist die ganze straßen voll oder nicht.
Und da also da geht noch 'ne menge irgendwie und trotzdem muss man sagen das was die da benutzen ist einfach mal ein paar klassen vor dem was ich hier zumindest gewohnt bin oder was hier so üblich ist.
Tja aber deutschland ist das wahrscheinlich zeit für alles wieder nicht erlaubt und dann brauchst du noch eine lizenz und dann kann's ja nicht mit der drohne über die leute rüber fliegen weil was könnte denn da passieren als vater also.
Selbst wenn du nicht die drohne nimmst nimm halt die ordentlich streamt kamera und macht die halt anderen drei meter ausklappt stativ oder vier meter,
und dann hast du halt ein der mit der kamera rennt und ein kamera operator der den gipfel bedient allein was du da für ein unterschied hast du den der mit dem wackeligen handy dazwischen steht ne also alleine wenn man sowas macht.
Ich hatte früher mal ein kumpel der hat am strand und so also vor weil sie nicht zehn jahren oder so,
mit so 'nem riesen zehn meter machst mit so einer gopro fotos gemacht also es war so ein,
machst oder von den funkamateur wenn die sonne ein paar gramm leichter antenne einfach hoch in die luft kriegen müssen also ein draht,
sieht aus wie eine andere gute.
Teleskop mass.
Genauso und der der wiegt halt nichts und es kostet vierhundert euro oder so
und der hat halt da oben drauf dann so eine von den ersten action camps gepackt und fotos gemacht einfach weil er die idee lustig fand und hat dann so im urlaub zum beispiel so den strand fotografiert aus zehn meter höhe mit dem weitwinkel foto,
wo ich dachte absolut irre wie unterschiedlich die welt da auf einmal aussieht,
und das war halt so zum spaß ein bisschen gespiegelt und alleine wie so eine aufnahme eine demo berichterstattung ändern würde.
Also ich denke mal es gibt so viele spannende möglichkeiten das,
das ist ja nur so die spitze vom eisberg was wir dort sehen aber es waren ja zum teil an den abenden zwanzig dreißig streams irgendwie
und auch so gekennzeichnet das ist jetzt dort da seht ihr mal da ist die polly university drin das ist der stream draußen und das ist jetzt aber irgendwie ein zehn wann
ich fand das auch schon irre weil das verglichen mit dem was ich hier kenne echt bahnbrechend ist.
Ja wie kommt ihr denn dann die berichterstattung hier in deutschland so vor jetzt was ja dann block post,
so mit den erfahrungen deiner shopping wall etcetera und es wurde dann gleich aufgegriffen ist mittlerweile in der tagesspiegel,
artikel umgearbeitet worden man denkt sich so okay was wenn du da jetzt nicht einen vortrag zufällig gehabt hättest,
hätte dann überhaupt irgendjemand noch berichtet und bei so einer daten lage,
gibt es nicht genug her sind einfach zu wenig kenntnis von vor ort vorhanden.
Keiner also.
Kein interesse daran oder ist man einfach über sättigt von der situation oder ist es schon so ja china macht ja eh was sie wollen und so egal es gibt genug andere sachen wir haben ja trump.
Also ich habe also die redaktion mit denen ich gesprochen habe.
Das ist das gleiche wie mit der kurdistan berichterstattung wo ich dann immer sagt mich freut 's ja wenn ihr mich fragt aber warum fragte mich ja brauch dreihundert vierhundert mitarbeiter und irgendwas.
Er bald nur im büro in berlin oder wo auch immer sitzen sag ich ja und irgendwie war der flughafen wieder kaputt oder also ich habe mich ein flugzeug gesetzt bin rübergeflogen warum macht ihr das nicht,
ja erstmal dann ist man ja abends nicht zuhause und wer soll denn das machen und wir haben ja auch kein für auch denkt okay ihr habt jemand der das macht seit zehn jahren.
Gibt's irgendeine möglichkeit das zu ändern also könnte man vielleicht sich mal so jemanden suchen mehr scheint aber bei vielen ist es wirklich das interesse.
Und versichert auch so spannend finde immer dieses dieses heu duo seine messlatte halten mit ja wir brauchen zwei unabhängige quellen.
Sag ja.
Das heißt also dein eigenen kollegen vertraust du so wenig dass er dich anlüge oder wie wenn er rüber fliegen würde,
also oder was soll mir das sagen und zum anderen.
Heißt ja aber wenn die fdp da oder reuther schreibe ich denke ey ich habe alleine dieses jahr vier d p anmeldung korrigieren lassen unter anderem weil sie gesagt haben die amis ziehen ihre truppen aus dem irak ab.
Sagte kann sein dass ihr syrien meint,
sagt da müssen sie die fachabteilung fragen das können sie so gar nicht sagen es hat dann tag gedauert bis sie die information hatten ah syrien,
tatsache also auf dem niveau zum teil also jetzt nicht mal spezial geheim kam.
Sondern einfach mal falsches land.
Oder so sachen was ich aber sehr bezeichnend finde was geschrieben dass irgendwo ein cafe mit einem maschinengewehr überfallen wurde,
ganz ehrlich ein maschinengewehr liegt wiegt so die neun zehn eher so zwanzig kilo und man braucht eigentlich zwei leute um das zu bedienen erstmal kann es sein dass ihr den sturmgewehr meintet wenn überhaupt.
Und zum anderen die der täter flüchtig und die waffe nicht gefunden und sie ist nicht abgefeuert worden dann könnt ihr überhaupt nicht sagen was es für eine waffe ist oder ob's nach treppe war dann plastik modell weil wenn das abgefeuert hätte man hat ein loch in der wand kann man sagen okay es war sicher eine schusswaffe,
und die antwort war so sinngemäß ja es ist ja so das sind details für für waffen narren oder so sagt nee entweder wollen wir faktenbasiert berichten oder nicht und das egal welches thema also so,
und zum anderen ja ich finde es ein unterschied ob man sagt hier hat jemand schwere kriegswaffen in dem zivilen gebiet eingesetzt oder vielleicht hat jemand 'ne plastik waffe bei gehabt also das ist ein,
massiver unterschied wovon wir da reden ne das ist jetzt nicht ein detail nur weil ihr es nicht versteht und wenn ihr eine agentur sein wollt an seriös dann sollte,
dann solltet ihr noch sagen scheiß egal was für ein komplexes thema das ist er sagt ja auch nicht da hat jemand zwei lustig gleich aussehende schafe
sondern nein es ging darum das schafe geklaut wurden da könnte man ja auch sagen also für mich als laie sieht das gleich aus ich verstehe den unterschied nicht wird man ja auch nicht durchgehen lassen,
oder wenn man sagt ja bei autos da kommt hinten so eine wolke raus und jetzt heißt es irgendwie dass es irgendwie anders wer soll den dieselskandal verstehen also aber wenn's um waffen geht ist ohne ein waffenarm und blöd.
Da dachte ich aber okay aber überhaupt wenn man so eine einstellung hat heißt das man vernachlässigt ein gesamtes thema weil man es cool findet keine ahnung von zu haben das sollte man sich bei journalismus nicht leisten können,
und da denke ich aber wenn das da ist wo noch also gibt es noch andere bereicherung.
Und dann aber wieder zu den redaktionen zurück also es interessiert ja kein man müsste hinfliegen die sachlage ist eh schlecht er sagt es gibt auch die ganzen streams,
man kann einfach mal davon ausgehen dass der stream echt ist also es wäre sehr aufwendig sonst stream zu faken also würde ich den als eine,
also zwar man sieht nur eine ecke jeweils von dem was passiert aber zum beispiel vor zwei tagen war das glaube ich.
Da wird so ein verletzte demonstrant von der polizei weg geschleppt und ein anderer kam an und hat ihm voll vom kopf getreten also wirklich so mit anlauf dass er weggeflogen ist.
Kann ich als sichere erkenntnis sehen also wer sollte denn das jetzt nach,
spielt und in den acht stunden stream von vor ort rein gefaket haben oder sowas ne da kann man sagen ja da gibt's übermäßige gewalt.
Und genau darüber hatte ich halt mit zwei redaktion hier in berlin auch gesprochen und die sagt mehr.
Erstmal wo findet man denn so streams also die selbst der china expert hatte davon nie gehört wo ich auch dachte alter wo lebt dir die ganze welt sitzt.
Liegt da die ganze zeit über twitter.
Ja aber das echt da will ich mir t-shirt vormachen twitter haben wir hier nicht installiert.
Das ist nicht dein ernst.
Während du hast im kopf durch wo fang ich überhaupt an also es ist ja nicht ein problem diese aussage es ist so so mehr richtig,
foto und wo ich dachte leute ihr seid jünger als ich,
so ihr c also wir reden jetzt nicht von neunzigjährigen leuten die da irgendwie mit dem rechten brett lagen sondern von leuten die so siebenundzwanzig achtundzwanzig waren.
Ernsthaft gott.
Aber haben das studiert und haben einen ordentlichen abschluss gemacht aber ja.
Ihre trump krise die irgendwie gefasst oder ausgedruckt.
Nee rate von der agentur ja wenn die ddr darüber berichtet es gab auch ein highlight.
Das war nicht hier das von einer anderen stadt 'ne redaktion mit der ich zu tun hatte als es um brexit kam ging gab es irgendeine pressemitteilung vom unterhaus wo irgendwas wichtiges drin stand und die haben gesagt ja ja auf der homepage vom unterhaus das sehen sie,
aber ist das irgendwie bestätigt.
Also ich hab erst gedacht ey okay ich habe entweder machen die sich einen spaß oder ich hab einfach den dümmsten erwischt der hier sitzt und im laufe der zeit ist mir das permanent so über den weg gelaufen.
Da ich auch gesagt selbst wenn ihr da mal ihr glaubt die ganzen streams sind nicht echt oder sagt das ist nicht von der fdp das kann ich nicht gucken keine ahnung was warum man sich selber so im weg steht oder sich selber auch so für,
ihr meint selber dass ihr nicht in der lage seid das zu beurteilen offensichtlich also ihr haltet euch selber für so dumm dass ihr nicht glaubt dass es dem leser erklären könnt dann.
Seit jetzt gerade zumindest ist paul wohnzimmer von der bild drüben höhe die bilder sag ich ja schön nachdem du dich ab der gehört hast ja der ist doof die lügen nur alles gut,
wen habt ihr nochmal drüben.
Also nase ja wir nicht weißt okay ihr seid also gerade schlechter als die bild können wir das so sagen oder habt ihr irgendeinen bessere quelle,
und zum anderen denkbar wohnzimmer kenne ich halt vor allem aus der kurdistan berichterstattung aber der ist halt überall auf der welt unterwegs.
Und da konnte ich ja vergleichen was hab ich neben ihm stehend oder sozusagen neben ihm am gleichen ort eine gleichen sachen gesehen.
Und was hat er nachher geschrieben das ist halt exakt alles richtig und gut analysiert und sonst was natürlich auch gedacht warum hab ich nie was von dem gelesen ich dachte da weil ich kein bild plus hab,
wie groß ist jetzt eigentlich die schnittmenge zwischen bild plus abonnenten und leute die hochwertige krisen berichterstattung haben wollen also zumindest kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass sie so groß ist von meinem empfinden her.
Wer hat halt gesagt naja ist relativ simpel keine andere redaktion lässt ihn einfach quer um die welt schatten und diesen ganzen kram berichten ohne eine sicherheit zu haben ob das bei rumkommt oder ob die leute klicken also er kann den job nur da machen.
Echt bildzeitung das sind die einzigen die jetzt.
Also die zumindest.
Reporter rumschicken.
Also von festangestellten eigenen reporter in krisengebieten kenne ich seit langem eigentlich nur die bild.
Dann hab ich leuten auch gesagt frag doch mal eure zeitung die ihr lest,
sagen sie ja das sind doch die berichte drin sagt nein nein nein nein frag mal wen sie da hatten oder ist das wieder nur abgeschrieben also,
so zusammen geklickt ne weil das macht einen massiven unterschied also zumindest bei so wie in hongkong wann sagt ja wie ist es jetzt genau wer also,
wo ja auch die gefahr hoch ist dass jemand blödsinn erzählt.
Und da gesagt okay aber wenn ihr sonst niemand vertraut frag doch oder guckt was bei rund zwei mal sagt der ist vor ort der es immerhin stellvertretender chefredakteur von europas größter zeitungen ob man's mag oder nicht,
ich wird zumindest nicht von ausgehen da sein sein mögt also mag ja sein dass der artikel nachher zum teil reißen frisch werden oder sonst was aber ich glaub nicht dass er die fakten verdreht in dem was er von dort erzählt also.
Glaub ich einfach nicht bei einem was ich erlebt habe und zum anderen wenn ihr's glaubt gut dann schick selber jemand hin dann werden wir wieder bei dem punkt kostet euch tausend euro für eine woche müsste doch gehen.
Oder guckt die streams an oder was auch immer also ich.
Tausend euro naja ein bisschen teurer ist schon eine woche da vor ort zu sein.
Ich habe gerade ein crowdfunding mitgemacht von einem der hinfliegt der braucht hm für flug und hotel achthundert.
Das ist aber ein günstiger flug.
Ja ich hab auch gestaunt vierhundertfünfzig hin und her und ja bei sarah selbst wenn 's zweitausend sind.
Man entweder willst du ordentliche berichterstattung oder nicht und theoretisch.
Müsstest du doch dann deine vor ort informationen aus gesicherten quelle gut verkaufen können,
und dann hast du wieder das problem das aber selbst die anderen zeitungen zum einen nicht von einer anderen zeitung sachen einkaufen wollen weil das tut man ja nicht weil es halt so in deutschland,
und zum anderen heißt wieder nah ich habe ja die agentur meldung die so sechzig prozent okay ist und meine leser kann es eh nicht bewerten.
Das billige.
Genau schön billig oder eben von dem billigsten freelancer den du vor ort findest.
Was ich halt auch immer so erbärmlich finde weil die leute machen exzellenten job und kriegen halt nichts richtig am ende für für den gefährlichsten teil und die die hier agentur meldung klicken verdienen oft mehr als der kriegs berichterstatter vor ort,
also das ist irgendwie so im system kaputt,
und aber der hauptpunkt den ich echt immer wieder erlebe ist dass es die leute nicht interessiert in den redaktionen also selbst wenn man ihn sagt da ist was falsch oder das kann nicht sein.
Dann heißt okay aber nicht dass sie sagen oh nein ich bin in meiner ehre als journalist gekränkt weil ich muss die wahrheit verbreiten und so weiter so,
wie man sich das ja im optimalfall vorstellen würdet waren wirklich so kann sein aber merkt das einer und warum also so,
einfach so kein anspruch an sich selbst und das macht mich echt am meisten wahnsinnig also wenn man,
sich was anguckt und kommt auf dem falschen rückschluss denke ich hey das passiert so das kann sein aber dann hast du dir zumindest was bei gedacht und bist irgendwo in die falsche richtung gekommen,
aber einfach zu sagen interessiert mich nicht denke ich dann werd nicht journalist also dann da macht was anderes.
Jetzt gleich zum
schluss also ich glaube das fehlt uns jetzt beiden schwer mir noch mehr als dir wahrscheinlich hier in irgendeiner form eine aussage darüber zu treffen wohin hier die reise geht aber aus all dem was ich so bisher gehört habe ist
ja nicht unbedingt davon auszugehen dass diese proteste jetzt in eine richtung gehen wo.
Auf einmal die sonne aufgeht und ganz hongkong für die nächsten zweieinhalb jahre in tadellose demokratie ergänzen lässt.
Nicht so richtig.
Ist ja,
geht's in die andere richtung man hat hier den eindruck china stammt sich diesen ort soweit,
zusammen das kann man auch im gespräch mit mario schon raus,
war das mal so ein wirtschaftlicher hotspot ist das heute im vergleich zu den angrenzenden städten irgendwo auch ein klacks.
Die situation so wie sie jetzt ist wird schon dazu führen führt auch schon dazu dass doch einige westliche,
unternehmer abziehen viele verlagern sich jetzt nach singapur weil sie das einfach tun können andere
kern vielleicht einfach zurück,
da so viele expertise ich zumindest auf so ein paar jahre mal festgeschrieben haben in irgendwelchen jobs gibt einen größeren bedarf lehrer et cetera das angebot ist da schwierig,
ich habe von der deutschen schule gehört die es dort gibt die interessanterweise da,
privat wirtschaftlich organisiert ist aber jetzt ob ihr auch beschlossen hat eigentlich gar nicht mehr so richtig in deutsch zu unterrichten wo ich mich dann auch fragen was jetzt also der deutsche
das ding ist aber da jetzt auch die schulen geschlossen sind und da der druck,
weiter zunimmt wenn sie natürlich viele auch fragen so okay muss ich jetzt meine,
hier in so einer situation hier betreut haben oder es dann doch nicht vielleicht,
wieder zurück in brandenburg zu sein.
Also ich sehe da auch also ich meine china wird nicht sagen hey sorry wir gehen wieder.
Tut uns leid es total übertrieben.
Genau sorry ich falsch verstanden hier google benutzt irgendwie falsch gelaufen.
Der ist ja eigentlich ganz geil er macht ja sogar coole podcast.
Genau der kennt den tim den müssen wir uns warm halten,
ja ich denke auch die frage ist nun ob das jetzt sehr schleichend oder sehr schnell geht.
Aber am ende seid klar wer am längeren hebel sitzt zum einen und zum anderen das ist die welt auch einfach nicht interessiert.
Also und selbst wenn sie die jetzt alle ab knallen würden und halt wie gesagt die hongkong regierung einfach streichen würden damit zeichnung oder verurteilen wir sehr können wir nochmal über den nächsten deal reden wir brauchen noch.
Zwei wochen noch schwarze arbeit haare auf twitter.
Genau so und ey aber das neue iphone stau schenken also ne das meine ich halt das ist so ja das verpufft.
Das verpufft tja das war dann unser beitrag unser optimistischer ausblick.
Robin für jeden tag.
Ja also da kriegt man wirklich ein ganz anderes gefühl für das topische gesellschaften wenn man ein paar tage rum gelaufen ist und wirklich so auf jeder fußgängerbrücke äh eine kamera
ins gesicht schaut aber was man so wir die wir auf unserer insel der glückseligkeit hier vor uns hin schwimmen und trotzdem alles scheiße finden,
manchmal nicht so die ganz die richtige perspektive was den rest der welt betrifft.
Nee es ist schon echt geil hier als das merke ich auch gerade wenn ich aus so gegen den komme oder wenn ich aus kurdistan zurückkam wenn's echt übel war.
So wirklich wenn man im flieger sitzt und weiß man hat den luftraum verlassen von irgendwie dagegen die eigentlich mag da da ist man schon sehr froh wenn man einfach weiß in deutschland.
Selbst in der schlechtesten relativen lage also wenn du hier auf hartz vier irgendwie in 'ner schmuddeligen wohnung auf einem dorf oder so wohnst.
Du kannst immer noch rausgehen und irgendwie schreiben ey fick dich merklich finde ich doof oder irgendwas,
und ich würde keiner für ab knallen also so dann sage ich mal leute ja ja nein wir sind hier die top zehn prozent der welt macht euch das ab und zu mal klar also nicht dass man immer sagen soll ich liebe das hier,
aber überhaupt dass man einfach mal so ein bisschen versteht die welt ist anders also auch wenn die leute sagen hey du musst mir trigger warum davor bringen wenn du jetzt.
Videos aus hongkong postest wo leute verprügelt werden.
Ja jetzt immer eine trigger warnung gemacht so achtung realität warnung die realität auf der welt ist anders als auf deiner,
insel dann haben leute sagt du nimmst das gar nicht ernst,
ja ich weiß nicht wer hier was nicht ernst nimmt das können wir jetzt in beide richtungen spielen ne.
Oh wei.
Aber ja wir wir haben es ziemlich gut hier.
Na gut zumindest haben wir jetzt hier die berichts pflicht erfüllt soweit es uns ermöglicht ist vielen dank.
Ja und ich hoffe das war ein wertvolles update für euch.